okay good morning everybody it's n
o'clock and I would like to start the
subcommittee work session on house on
Senate Bill
485 and um I welcome our um maybe the
three or the four of you can quickly say
your names starting with Mr Perry and
then we can um we won't have to so uh
Warren Perry Deputy agent General New
Hampshire Department military Affairs
and veter
services my name is Scott wro I'm with
Merit International and I'm the lead for
the Aspire Coalition which works on
Military Reciprocity for spouses across
the
country good morning I'm Eric Taylor and
I'm a lobbyist for uh marid
SP good morning lindsy Courtney
executive director office of
professional Li Insurance
certification okay so we're thank you
everybody we're meeting here because um
when we've heard Senate Bill 485 last
week we noticed that it was remarkably
similar to House Bill
1385 so the objective of uh the meeting
is to look to see what we need to do to
make to to Senate Bill 485 to to make it
harmonious with Senate bill with House
Bill 1385 or
um oop sorry if Senate Bill uh 485 is
needed at all in light of house bill
1385 so um representative Carol would
you like to um discuss what you the
analogy the the comparisons that you
made on both the bills uh thank you sure
good morning
everybody
uh so let's see I don't know if
everybody has a copy of
each um of the amendment to 1385 which
is 1090
I got one we can share and is that
Amendment did that replace the bill in
its entirety yes
okay um and that's what we voted on here
in committee yes and then
485 so I I think that the short
explanation is there's a number of
changes that we made in uh uh 1385 in
the amendment that were at the
suggestion of oplc and
DMV uh clarifying language to go along
with all the changes that you folks have
made in the past few years and some
language to make sure that active that
that people transitioning that we made
sure put the word veterans in there to
make sure that that was clear and not
just spouses so most of that is what
this is as as a uh uh looking from the
30,000 foot view um I think the main
piece of 485 was at the senator was
looking for the digitally
verifiable
um licensing piece and and there's an
entire paragraph of the back that was
added that I think oplc and DMV should
put in for should put in the comment on
so with that said I don't know if you
want me to kind of go if it makes sense
just to go through it a little bit line
at a time so do we
um uh you're welcome to to use that that
waren if if you want to and I didn't
have any extra copies of 1385 my
apologies for that but so going down
this little uh comparison sheet so on
1385 on the amendment page one in its
entirety isn't addressed in 485 because
it's all new material that we put in so
there's no change needed on 1090 and
it's not
relevant um on page
1385 just a moment I just want to make
sure so um we don't have any say in 1090
anymore because it's gone to the Senate
but do we the fact that it's not
addressed in Senate Bill 485 is that an
issue um those first two lines are not
an
issue because 485 doesn't address any of
that okay and is that something then
that okay that's fine okay so we don't
need to do anything okay uh um on 1385
in page two the changes that we made in
the title added veterans and it removed
the words temporary
license and I would think that that
should also be reflected in 485 if I'm
understanding the process correctly and
certainly director Courtney can jump in
but I think that those were changes
suggested by oplc and dmav to make our
our bill make sense so I would say that
what's on page two line 8 in 138 5
should be put into 485 if that's the
process okay does anybody does anybody
have any comments on
that yeah I would agree with that
representative
okay the next line down again similar
changes that were were suggested by OPC
I think clarifying
language um
uh words were added as you can see under
RC 45a and the word the' was added to
make a make the sentence
grammatically more proper and it deleted
the words of the officer of professional
licenser and certification because we
changed that globally across all of our
bills so I believe those changes should
be put into 485 as
well
okay any comments you're good everybody
good okay I think my only comment would
be that I think the language that's in
um at least one and we can talk about
the other Roman numerals but I think the
language that's in
1385 is probably the language that we
want to keep whether or not it be moved
over to 485 or whether it just be taken
out of 485 and we rely on 13 95 however
we want to do that I think that's the
language that the office would
like okay it's just minored yep that's
fine that's fine right and and I don't
know enough about how this works to know
so right what we had in 1385 I think we
want to keep whether we have to put that
in 485 or in the long run it changes the
law when they're both done it changes
the law regardless right right so up
until now what I my sense is that
there's nothing that's in 485 that is
not in
1385 as amended and that 1385 as amended
represents the latest version of is that
are we all in agreement with
that okay so if if you want me to jump
to where I think there's a conflict yes
um uh can I just you may
yeah just so uh can think about the
direction we're we're
headed uh there is an an opportunity
here maybe to in to change and then
endorse
1385 and maybe reject 485
as like the committee already passed
1385 amended with 1098 we did that
already so we're not going to amend it
again we're not amending it so what
we're doing is we're looking at 485 to
either correct conflicts or just add
something new or to even determine if we
need 4 485 because it might be that at
the end the day the corrections that we
might to make to 485 are going to be
such that all it's an improvement of
1385 so so if we if if we were to
endorse 485 yes would there have to be
some Committee of conference to put the
the two bills together to uh work out
differences well if we were to change
the 4 485 significantly enough we would
ask the Senate to concur with our
changes right we wouldn't have we
wouldn't have to we could do that in a
discussion with the Senate with the
Senate Edna
group thank you sure go ahead um Mr
representative Brown so let's go down to
where it says page three line 2 through
five on HB 1385 so that is on 485 if you
have it it's page two lines 8 through
11 where it says the executive un
let me back up one more to where it says
not addressed in 1385 so the on page two
line 2 through
7 the word
commensurate appear I'm I'm making the
note that the word commensurate appears
in 1385 farther down and in here it does
say the old language is substantially
similar that I think we talked about it
at nauseum this session whether we
wanted that in there or not so I guess I
would leave that to others
to I'm just making the
point
um
yeah representative Courtney do you have
a comment on
that director Coury thank you so I think
that the language in 1385 was distilled
down to what we'd like it to be in terms
of requiring the office to adopt rules
to to determine what military training
education experience is um acceptable to
basically obtain a license I think that
the distinction is that the language um
in 485 includes that language that
Senator Carson was interested in which
includes digitally verifiable license
and that's not included in
1385 um but in terms of directing the
office
to uh adopt rules establishing you know
the basis for obtaining a license I
think the language in 1385 is is the
preferable
language do you agree with that so so
yeah my my two cents are the the benefit
of 485 is it just adds the digitally
verifiable license piece and the more
the more exactly the same the language
is the better because it just avoids
Confusion And depending on which one of
these gets signed Last by the governor
that's what becomes the statute right so
want them to be the same we want the
language to be the same and at the end
of the day it's just it's just happy to
Glad in terms of commensurate versus you
know substantially similar so they we
should be looking to modify 485 so the
language is exactly the same as it is in
1385 as amended and that that's just it
it makes sense and what we get out of
485 rather than kill it is the is the
digitally verifiable piece so that's an
advantage and if that's what you want
incent Bill 485 that's the part we can
just make that
a
uh an amendment to 1385 right because
because if this if the governor signs
1385 and then in 480 485 we we add the
digital the the least the what I'm
trying to say
is um we should use the least number of
words in 485 so we don't have conflict
and we do what we wanted to do and at
the end of the day representative I
think that achieves the intent that the
department would like to see okay so
really with 485 what we're really
looking for is the digitally verifiable
license piece so what we're looking for
is on
page one of the bill from line
26 right starting at 26 because that
that's the section that has the digital
licensing it's on page two line three to
facilitate the license of a licensed
digitally verifi license certificate I
mean that's
where that's what we want to do correct
yes yes
ma'am Lindsay does what I said make
sense I mean it yes it makes complete
sense we've had issues with enrollment
in the last couple of years uh when
there are conflicts in the law um I
think you could do it that way I think
you could just essentially take what's
in 1385 and put it in 485 the other
thing you could do is just is just
remove anything in 485 except the
requirement that we adopt procedures to
establish D digitally verifiable
licenses you could do it that way as
well and it would be a fairly small bill
so my preference is to make things as
small as possible because you never know
how these things are going to you I
don't want to get get tripped up later
because of some Clause that we put in
that we didn't know was going to be a
conflict does that make
sense and I think that you know it it
probably is worth our time to reach out
to the prime sponsor in the Senate and
say this is we've done this already in
1385 and we're just gonna we're going to
pair this down to avoid conflicts and my
gut tells me that Senator Carson would
be amable to that my gut tells me that
yes and she I just met her in the uh on
the way over here and she's going to
spend a significant part of her morning
here and that's something we can discuss
with her so if everyone is
agreeable that will be the discussion
that I have with her yes
yes um yeah and and just to underscore
the importance of having that language
in there for the portability of licenses
for military spouses or Veterans as they
move from one state to another that's
absolutely essential um by it's not just
a matter of having an online or digital
application and processing uh system in
place but it's also the ability for
spouses take those licenses which are
verified digitally with them into new
places when they permanently change
station for example and facilitate their
ability to be recognized more quickly
and again get to work more quickly as
well yes um representative Brown thank
you so on page two of 485 y so that
starting on line two that entire
paragraph that says the procedure shall
that entire paragraph is added and it
looks like it only has to do with
digitally verifiable licensing so uh uh
General Perry and director Courtney are
you okay with that entire paragraph
because that's not in 1385 that whole
paragraph is starting with the procedur
shall include
okay actually down to line seven sorry
MH
I I think I'm comfortable with that
language I will
say we currently have the
language in our statute that requires us
to facilitate the issuance of a license
and no one really knows what that means
in terms of implementing so if there is
an opportunity I think to to clarify
exactly what what what that means to
facilitate a license I think the
language the procedure shall include um
it works for us but I think it has
created confusion when we've implemented
this Statute in the
past it's fine with me if it's fine with
everybody
else I'm good with it as long as it's
consistent you know the substantially
similar language is consistent across
all of the statutes right so and I and I
I get confused you know where we use
commerate where we use substantially
similar and I know that was a you know
that was a a pretty uh substantial
debate earlier uh but so as long as it's
the same and we don't have this other
you know we don't we don't create some
other sense of Confusion by like just
non non exactly the same
language so would it make sense to
change those two words to commensurate
as we've put that in 1385
already I think it should be consistent
with 138
5 say say again sorry I think it should
be consistent with
1385 so that's on line five we would
remove suly similar and put
commensurate
right starting with line two at the end
yes right and then I have a comment on
uh section three the same page line 16
and 17 procedure for issuing digitally
verify licenses do we is that
in is that is Clause 38 I'm sorry three
starting with line H is that all in
the okay so we should probably put
everything from the procedure down to
the very end or is
that I'm just I'm just verifying here
yeah that and I think that gets at
Lindsay's comment about how do we do
this and this says do it by rules right
I mean essentially that's what that
said yes so I think you could just add a
requirement that we adopt
procedures
um you know essentially copy the
language that's in 485 right now and
just give us that rule making
obligation so yeah there there's some
slight differences so on 485 on on page
three on line 10 MH it says what
constitutes military education training
or service acceptable blah blah blah but
in what we approved in 1385 it
says for what constitutes commenor
military education training or service
so it and then it does refer to 337 g7i
which is one which is what one of the
main things we wanted to make sure we
didn't miss so that language is a little
different
uh
uh BC and D on 485 aren't in
our uh Amendment 1385 Amendment yeah I I
don't I I don't know if that those are
needed or not director if that's
something you have elsewhere or if
I so that would be lines 12 uh 12
through 17 on 485 page
two
so I think arguably we already have rle
making Authority for
b
c we probably already have it for D our
Ru making Authority is pretty broad with
respect to
procedures I think if it were me and I
were just going
to do this what what I would do is I
would obviously
1385 is moving forward I would do a
repeat in replace um or an amendment to
replace the entirety of 485 and
basically just establish another
provision under
31016 setting forth exactly what a
digitally verifiable license is a
requirement that the office uh make
available uh or use digitally verifiable
licenses at least for military service
members and then give the office roeming
Authority and I think that would
accomplish uh Senator Carson's intent
assuming she's she would be agreeable to
moving in that direction I think that
would be the cleanest route as opposed
to trying to crossw walk this and make
sure that there aren't any
conflicts so saying that do you want to
help us write the amend the the re the
amended version of 485 I I can certainly
do that
um and I know and I'm and I'm happy to
talk to Senator Carson too about that to
make sure she would be comfortable with
that approach right so in summary what
we're saying is we're going to
add on page two from line two to line
seven that
paragraph and then we're going
to give the oplc
office Clarity on the procedure for
issuing digitally verified licenses is
that what we're
saying
yes and I would just make sure we have R
making authority to flesh that
out
okay and then there's one more piece yep
so on the second page I what I handed
you if if you recall um when when this
came through the
committee the history of this is that
332 G7 requires all boards to create a
crosswalk and a matrix and they haven't
done it so uh director Courtney said
that oplc would pick up that
responsibility and guaranteed rules
would be done within whatever frame we
put in under the boards that were for
the boards that are under oplc which
leaves a few boards outside of that we
didn't put that amendment in 1385
because it was too late we didn't change
that so the second page that I handed
you is what we had agreed on I think
between uh General Perry and director C
Courtney um about an amendment to cover
the boards that are not under oplc so
this would be an
addition to 485 then so you're talking
about Clause
four yes uh if it ends up being four at
that point
yes right I remember that
conversation does anybody have any
comments on that no okay and I and I
don't think director there's no no
reason that some of those lines are bold
particularly I think that was my
error all right so does anybody else
have any comments because if not I think
we've done
our work for the
subcommittee yes so there was some
concern in the committee about whether a
digitally verifiable licensing piece was
necessary and I think the senator wants
that
is someone here that can explain exactly
what that
is because the director had said we have
some capability already or or is it not
a thing I need to worry
about so I do think that representative
McGuire made a few comments and there's
a desire to have that better fleshed out
um as to what exactly that
entails I'm not the person to be able to
do that so
if I mean mer Meritt is very happy to
present uh what this looks like uh we've
been working very closely with a number
of other states to include Kansas Rhode
Island Illinois on on what this looks
like and and what shape that could take
so we could definitely organize
something for either the subcommittee or
for yourself or both uh in in in terms
of what that could potentially look like
for you so we're we're more than happy
to to do
that okay great I think it would be
helpful to have some language as
essentially you know if if the office is
going to have an
obligation to have a system or software
or whatever that may be I think we need
to have that better defined in statute
and so is there some language that you
could send me that I can include in the
in the draft proposed amendment that
would better better
Define what is meant by a digitally
verifiable
license I I actually already made a note
uh to to to to get you some uh to take a
look at so uh as soon as we're finished
here I'll be in touch with uh with with
my people and then uh I'll pass it along
to Eric to to to provide to you perfect
yes just and I think what just go back
to lay people right not not experts in
licensing but just a definition right
that's I think that's what we're looking
for a definition of digitally verifiable
license that's really what we're looking
for right that's I think that's the
question you asked okay yeah thank you
sorry that's
okay speaking a different
language make sure
question so I just want to confirm then
what we'll do is um we'll have an
amendment for next Wednesday on the 17th
we'll have a very short subcommittee
meeting where we can agree on the
amendment and thanks everybody for your
work and your dedication for coming
today
he
e
sorry representative
Bron uh chair Maguire is in Senate Edna
at the moment so um she asked me to get
the public hearings going so it being 10
o'clock I'm going to open the public
hearing on SB 599 and welcome
representative Greta to introduce the
Bill thank thank you Mr chair um so
Senate Bill 599 is relative to the state
fire code you might know that the um
building code is one is a bill that we
passed in the house in our in our um
committee recently and the state codes
are independent of the building codes
and that's why they require a separate
bill and I'm here just to introduce the
bill and I'm sure there are other people
here who could speak about it more apply
thank you very
much Sean
Tumi
good morning Sean Tumi the State Fire
Marshall for the record thank you for
allowing me to speak this morning um so
as representative mentioned the state
fire code is is separate from the
building code uh we are currently in the
2018 edition of the uh State Fire code
our goal is in the codes as we've heard
is to stay one code cycle behind we are
uh looking to move forward with the 2021
codes which would be NFPA 1 and 101 at
this point do you want me to
pause yeah I knew you were busy so
Jackie just introduced it so good I'll
finish it for you sorry Mr Jimmy no no
problem um so we're as I said going to
the 20121 addition of the codes the uh
Board of Fire Control and my office have
uh worked together with stakeholders to
look at necessary amendments there was
public hearings with the board of Fire
Control uh and we uh had uh several
carry amendments and then I'll go over a
couple other amendments that we're doing
uh they were heard in public hearing
passed uh we moved it to the advisory
the legislative advisory on building
fire codes and received support from
that committee and then moved to a bill
so a couple of the highlights for the
moving from the 2018 to 21 in the uh
requirements for restaurants and bars
the in the assembly aumy so anything
over 50 people the 21 codes were going
to get much more aggressive on the
requirements for sprinklers so uh
anything over 50 would require uh
sprinkler system for even a small
restaurant and uh so what we did was we
chose to keep it the same as what we are
today um and no change from the 2018s we
we thought that that would be uncessary
B burden on uh folks in New Hampshire to
try to have to sprinkle like a small
Diner or something like that uh
similarly on daycares uh all new
daycares were going to be required to be
sprinkled uh and instead of uh
regardless of size and things like that
so we kept it to maintain the same
requirements under the 2018 chapter um
there were some requirements that came
into play and there's a fight about um
portable generator spacing and then you
can read um anywhere from 5T up to 20 ft
of the distance between a port for a
portable generator away from a house we
know we want people not to run their
generators in their homes in their
garages because of their fear of carbon
monoxide poison
um so you can run a stationary generator
about 5 ft from your house um but we so
we thought it was a little bit
unnecessary to say that to force someone
to go to 20 ft um most of the people
that have the cord sets preset cord sets
are not set up to go that distance so
then people would be doing some funny
stuff electrically which we thought
would be add risk so uh we're going to
keep the distance um as it is in the
2018 codes and just encourage people to
get them as far away from their homes
and open window openings and door
openings as we can to minimize any
dangers around carbon monoxide
protection so maintaining what we have
is is the kind of the trend I would tell
you that the biggest uh amendment that
we dealt with is the the issue about res
residential sprinkle protection for
existing uh dwelling units up to four
four so we've had the uh exemption for
sprinklers for one and two family homes
on the books for quite some time uh we
are seeing a lot of inquiries lately um
you know think the old Main Street um
buildings that were once all residential
somewhere along the line they went to a
commercial like a business use on the
first floor and now they're looking to
go back to residential and uh maybe
adding one or two units on that first
floor where there's two above say that
would require the whole building to be
sprinkled um which was pretty uh uh
difficult to do when a lot of cases um
in some cases if there was Municipal
Water it cost more money to get into the
street to get to the water then it would
be to sprinkle the entire building um
and you know there's not room to put
tanks and pumps and things like that so
what we decided to do is um say that for
up to four units on a uh existing
building it just needs to meet the
existing apartment chapter so it would
be very unlikely that it would require a
sprinkler unless there's some really
weird unique circumstances they're
trying to stuff something on a like in
an attic or down in a basement with no
windows or something like that but
generally speaking this would allow uh
conversions of four units um to not have
to had to add sprinkler systems um and
just meet the existing chapters so that
was probably the most debated one but I
think we got to a good compromise we
balance Life Safety we meet the existing
codes um so we have a benchmark for
safety I think there the rest of it uh
amendments were carry forward amendments
and some cleanup of existing um you
remember crop mazes we've we pulled out
quite some time ago we removed Board of
appeal language and let that fall back
to the locals uh we we maintain some
language on the frequency of existing
inspections in the 2018 they came up
with a a schedule of required
inspections so last year we took it out
figuring that that should be a decision
for the locals based on Staffing and
decisions that the town makes but the
guidance was there um we did some uh
last year or two years ago we did some
language on solar to help make it easier
to put solar on roofs in New Hampshire
we've maintained that langu which so
there's a lot of M the kind of
maintaining existing so I H I can go
through it all but uh I can share it in
an email if you'd like the a little bit
more of the detail um and I'm happy to
answer any questions but so that that's
kind of the highlights I hope you can
support moving forward to the 2021 helps
us keep Pace with the technology Keeps
Us in Pace with that kind of staying
threeyear behind cycle um so happy to
answer any questions that you may have
thank you very much for your testimony
representative men
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question you briefly went over the
catching up with the technology solar um
and those uh caught my attention have
you also looked at the storage batteries
that the
residential uh component
that you know not just uh
multi-unit but also single single Le
family with that has there been any
adjustment to presence of backup battery
solar other components that have added
to the mix sure thank you so we did uh
adopt trying to see you but the things
in the way sorry uh we did adopt NFP 855
as part of the package in the last cycle
which addresses commercial and has a
residential component for uh energy
storage systems uh it it asks typically
to have like a 5/8 sheetrock 1H hour
rating and whatever space um you're uh
putting the battery storage which is
most of the time people putting them in
garages and that would uh historically
be uh sheetrocked anyways if you have up
against living quarters so we do have
some guidance um I will tell you it's
not caught up with some of the current
concerns around battery lithium ion
batteries in general but I think we have
a good we're in a good spot at this
point in time for that we do have
guidance on the books follow
up
so has the to follow up to that has the
firefighting techniques have adopted to
putting out battery
fires so that wouldn't be in the code
where um there's a lot we're learning a
lot as a fire service about batteries um
and there's a lot of studies going on
nationally about batteries uh what we do
know is it typically takes much more
water and more time uh the batteries uh
if they get into that thermal Runway
State they don't typically want to go
out so it's uh you know we know we know
what's going on it's a more challenging
fire I and I think that we've done a
pretty good job in New Hampshire about
educating that through the fire academy
messaging through my office and through
the New Hampshire Fire Chiefs
Association and the professional
firefighters we're just sharing out as
much information as we can to keep our
firefighters safe in the
state representative dlan thank you Mr
chair um thank you for taking my
question I have a
there's
a a uh a proliferation of of what we
call adus or additional dwelling units
in in legislation and in
practice what if anything do do you or
do we need to be thinking of as more and
more of these uh alternative structures
uh to to be residing in uh as they
become more popular
more more prevalent is there anything we
need to do to adjust our fire codes or
or to alert uh local fire stations of
how to how to manage uh a fire and
something like that uh thank you I think
we're in relatively good shape on the
fire code side of things like I the the
things that come to my mind in those
situations are working smok and carbon
monoxide alarms and and means of Escape
right just like in the home hopefully
that we're living in now and the our
fire codes currently address that pretty
well I think the the the only potential
challenge might be is the uh requirement
for the sprinkler system um and you know
I think we're if we're in one dwelling
unit and we add an Adu for say a family
member something like that um one to two
is easy we're covered I think the the um
Amendment that's before us right now to
go up to four units would uh help
alleviate the cost around sprinklers but
then still keep us safe CU it follows
our existing code does that answer your
question yes thank you thank
you representative
Gera thank you Mr chair so fire Marsh
Tumi you offered to send to us a summary
of the changes and if you could kindly
do that I'd appreciate it I would happy
to do that thank you thank you yes
representative leus thank you I think I
heard you say in passing something about
changes related to a board of appeal
what what was that about yeah yeah so
the in the uh in the NFPA 1 which is
part of the fire code there's a it
spells out a board of appeals process
and um we've taken that out so it can be
dealt with at the local level someone
can still come to a variance to my
office and then appeal it through the
building code review board so we still
have that side of the process we're not
removing any of that it's more of the
local the local official I'm sorry the
local uh board of appeals process so um
that's we've reserved that for the
locals just follow up follow up so was
there a requirement before for some
local board of appeals in addition to
the the state the um there's other
language on appeals uh in different
parts of the statute now so um there's a
requirement for building code uh
building code appeals boards at the
local level and typically it will go
through there um sometimes that's a
board of Selectmen sometimes that's a
zoning board right there's there's a
another bill that's here uh I think it's
part of the next bill that will have um
if the bill if the the the code appeal
stuff goes to uh like a zba instead it
would might potentially go to the
building code review board for someone
that would be more uh familiar with the
code process rather than um someone that
doesn't have familiar with the code
process so there's local systems in
place it was just trying to not have uh
overlap or conflicting documentation
that's been out for a long a long long
time all right thank
you yes representative
Goldie thank you Mr chair um thank you
for being here just one quick question
this uh deals with all the Amendments uh
as of September 20th there hasn't been
any other after that has there that we
need to include correct we haven't done
any additional amendments at this
time any other questions yes
representative Gard thank you
chairman is there any metrics to
determine if increasing the stringency
of the fire code is decreasing property
damage and deaths or it's just something
we we feel we need to do because
everyone else is doing it I'm just
curious um so that's a tough one right
um
NFPA is probably the National Fire
Protection Association is probably the
best to attract uh historical data um
which is based on uh incident reporting
from the local fire departments and uh
and many many cases code changes we can
see is a steep decline in uh dollar loss
and uh injuries and deaths um and
there's charts for each of the different
occupancies um you'll on the sprinkler
requirement which I I think that bill is
going to come to you guys at some point
there's a separate bill on the sprinkler
for three and four family one of the
decision points on why we chose to do
the three and four fam is that that
curve has essentially been flat when you
did the um sprinkler versus the when
when the sprinkler requirement came in
when the when smoke alarms came into
play in the 70s we saw a steep decline
in the deaths around uh in residential
structures so um I think some you see a
greater return quicker um and others you
don't but there there's there is some
data I can share this I can share the
reports with you uh if you if you'd like
uh followup followup I appreciate that
but is this New Hampshire specific or
this is more National based uh New
Hampshire uh National basee we don't we
don't we haven't drilled into that uh
local it's something we're trying to
start working on now uh we have a
part-time data person they barely keep
up with just shifting the stuff to the
US fire Administration for their stuff
so I appreciate I just my personal
concern is that this is a major
financial burden on some people and I
just want to know that there is actual
return versus just sure so thank you I
don't I would you're welcome I don't um
one of the things we consider obviously
in the amendment process and the
adoption process is looking at the costs
uh there's um you know we don't
anticipate it's very difficult to figure
out the exact cost but unlike the
building code and the energy code
conversations we've had right we don't I
can't point to one one thing other than
the ones we took out the sprinklers uh
of saying this is going to be a big
increase in cost for developers um if we
add for the sprinklers for like the bars
and restaurants that would be a big
change especially in areas in our state
that have no Municipal Water um and the
daycare would have a big impact on the
availability of child care and um I have
a sick half sickish kid with me but um
uh you know the child care thing is a
big issue right so if we add burden to
the sprinkler requirement on something
that's been pretty safe for years Based
on data um that's why we backed it off
so I think we do a pretty good job on
the fire cat side of um balancing all
those requirements all right thank
you any other question questions yes
representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman uh good
morning for Marshall so
uh are we seeing a um
a kind of a steady situation with fires
or are we seeing that the number of
fires is going down as people for
example one of the one of the things is
uh smoking was was a very frequent cause
of fires right people fall asleep in bed
with a cigarette burn their house down
uh people's habits are changing a
lot so are we seeing a result uh I I
remember seeing um neighbors of mine
they were both
smokers he he would they'd come outside
after a while I see them come outside to
smoke then they stop
smoking um and so can you speak to that
issue sure so generally speaking I would
say fires are down um we see about
approximately 12 fire fatalities in New
Hampshire each year um our fire losses
in New Hampshire generally now uh either
heating related or cooking related um
and largely when we see the the
fatalities it's uh unfortunately due to
lack of working smoke alarms um but
Heating and cooking tend to be our our
biggies and New Hampshire but um there
is a sort of a maybe a little bit of
upward Trend uh nationally that we're
looking at and concerned with and it's
um you know we talk about the batteries
issues that we're watching closely to
see what that's going to do um you know
the the changes in construction types
and and the progression of how fast
fires move uh changes in furniture and
and things like that that the synthetics
uh burn quicker so you know it's a lot
of these things take time uh for them to
vet out but um I would say generally
over the last several decades we've seen
an a downward Trend and and fire loss uh
the New Hampshire fire ad fire
department's largely response to Medical
calls at this point not fire calls um
fortunately but um still still busy
enough so uh so some of that is it would
be in response to people's habits
changing but also uh I mean I know I see
on I'm online a lot I see on YouTube I
see tremendous amount of advertising for
all kinds of gear to protect yourself
from everything imaginable um and one of
the things obviously out there is home
uh not only smoke detectors but also uh
fire suppression equipment uh and can
you can you different
differentiate between the difference
between individual habits changing for
example number smokers is going down uh
but also um stuff like fire
extinguishers and so forth and the I see
this thing where they got this
cloth that you throw on the fire on the
pan that's on fire right uh so new gear
uh so can you speak to that just getting
off subject here to the fire code I I i'
would agree with that I'm not sure
that's pertaining specifically to the
fire code that we're dealing with in the
bill so okay thank
you yeah yes representative Brown thank
you Mr chair thank you Fire Marshall
take my question is there anything in
this code that
would uh impact the types of fuel that
you can use at home
and any drive towards in Iving solar
power no thank
you any further
questions sing on thank you very much
for your time thank
you we'll get there in time um Brendan
no Sullivan ter
far
morning my name is Brendan ulvan I'm
here from durm fire department and I
support this bill as written and I'm
happy to take any
questions thank you very much any
questions I think Mr Tumi got most of
them yeah thank you very much you did
thank
you Dave Emanuel New Hampshire associ
Fire
Chiefs thank you Mr chair uh my name is
Dave Emanuel I am the President of the
New Hampshire Association of Fire Chiefs
and our goal is to provide leadership
education and advocacy for the New
Hampshire fire service I am also the
chief of the Durham fire department and
we just wanted to thank you for your
consideration and we wanted to show our
support for this bill mainly because at
a local level it's practical to be one
code cycle behind uh and no not further
than that because the technology changes
and it's important that our that our
state Paces the national codes and best
management practices and it does impact
us on the local level and uh on behalf
of New Hampshire Association of Fire
Chiefs we support this proposal thank
you thank you for your testimony any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you for your time Philip
Sherman building Cod revie review board
yeah oh it is so it is and so is this
one
perfect Mr chairman is this going to
subcommittee uh I don't believe so good
no I think I think we're probably good
okay um is there anybody else who would
wish to speak on S
sp599 seeing none I will close the
public hearing and um we'll move over to
Executive session on the S sp599 do I
have a motion
yes Mr chair I move out of pass on
Senate Bill 599 second seconded by
representative Goldie would you like to
speak to your motion representative grto
yes I would um thank you um I believe
that several uh comments that were made
today were appropriate to this uh to
this bill first of all we've agreed to
stay one Cod behind on the fire codes
and this will put us exactly where we
need to be the other is that the um
codes and the the ratification and
revisions were considered in lie of the
um business climate and the uh
residential needs of the people of New
Hampshire so with those two um important
um and I like the fact that the the
board of appeal was moved to a local
level so these are all reasons why we
should adopt this
Bill thank you representative fol would
you like to speak to your second thank
you Mr chair and I think uh
representative Gro covered it all um
just want to thank the uh Fire Marshall
for those amendments coming forward I
think they'll help out the small
businesses here in New Hampshire thank
you anybody else like to say anything
yes representative Brown thank you Mr
chair I'd like to Echo that I think it's
really important and and I thank you all
for taking into consideration the cost
to businesses and to to the residents of
the state for the position we're in
right now so thank you for
that yes representative M py thank you
Mr chair I just want to Echo um my
colleagues and also add to it that as
the technology and as the society is
changing with the new technologies new
tools available for residential as well
as commercial keeping an eye on the
battery storage and not saying we are
not going to go there but keeping an eye
on the growth in Economic Development I
second that thank
you would anybody else like to
comment seeing none uh the motion is
ought to pass on SB 599 and the clerk
can call the
role representative uh lakas yes
representative Bailey
yes representing
Dolan representing geard
yes clerk votes yes representative voyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmid yes representative goalie yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative
Smith yes representative man py yes and
the chair yes 15 y z n the motion passes
1 15 Z do I have um anybody opposed to
consent seeing none we'll put that on
the consent calendar and um we've got
about 3 minutes until our next hearing
and Mr Timmy if you wouldn't mind still
sending out that email that would be
great
e
have in our State Building uh codes um
it was a hardfought bill a lot of
compromise and uh it eventually passed
and the governor signed that particular
bill into law but what happened was
there was a window between the time time
it was signed into law and the time um
that it became effective and what I
discovered because it was brought to my
attention that some municipalities took
advantage of that time frame that a
couple of months and passed a lot of um
local ordinances concerning the state
their version of the State Building Code
in my opinion that was something that
was not appropriate the bill was signed
it just had not taken effective and I
felt that the municipalities that did
this took an unfair um advantage of that
time period especially when um we were
working on the bill and they had come in
and asked for that time period not to
have it take effect
immediately so um that's one reason why
I filed um Senate Bill
437 I felt it was entirely inappropriate
for them to do
this
um the other thing and if you remember
about that original legislation what it
did was it said look you can adopt these
local codes but if you're going to do
that before you put them on a ballot or
you adopt them submit them to the to the
State Building Code review board they
can look at them they can't tell you
that you can't adopt them but as you
know the uh State Building Code review
board they're responsible for putting
all of these together and anyone and
Builders electricians plumbers they look
at that because those are the building
codes and if a municipality is going to
go beyond that they should also know
that as well and the State Building Code
review board is the Clearing House it's
the place where people go to find
information so you know again that's why
that original bill was filed so let me
talk a little bit more about this um
Bill the main purpose of this bill and
the accompanying amendment is to clarify
the rsas that are in place now with
regards to following the State Building
Code so that it follows the intent of
the legislature at the time it was
passed this bill requires all local
ordinances amending the state building
code to comply with the procedures in
law for review and approval of
additional local regulations to the
State Building
Code excuse me it also closes loopholes
allowing for entire codes to be adopted
with disregard to the most recently
adopted State Building Codes now all of
you you know because we have a bill in
Edna concerning an update of the
building code um the build State
Building Codes we are two years behind
this is something that the Senate Edna
and house Edna at the time agreed upon
because what was happening they were
lagging far beyond two years and there
were some serious ramifications for that
lag including um higher Insurance costs
on buildings because they were not
building they especially commercial
buildings were not being built to
updated codes and because of that it was
costing people who own commercial
buildings more money in their in their
insurance for the buildings so between
your chair and myself who chaired our
Senate Edna at a time we created a
method and it it's worked there's no
fighting there's no ARG arguing they
work it out and then they come to the
legislature with what they've what
they've worked on and this committee has
passed them as well as uh Senate
Edna so um again um I I digress a little
bit because I was really kind of
concerned at the Brazen behavior that
had occurred during that small time
period where some municipal alties just
adopted State Building Codes the whole
thing an updated version that is
contrary to what this legislature
adopted we know that the building codes
come through
here so anyway there's also conern uh
consistency in wording and location when
looking at the bill there were a few
locations throughout New Hampshire's
rsas that touch on the requirements
which allow adoption of
additional uh codes or amendments this
particular Bill attempts to make the
wording consistent and then simplifies
where to find the wording in the law by
using RSA
474 colon 51 and 47 colon 22 both which
Define The Authority given to local
municipalities these two sections Define
the intent and then it simply
refers any other locations where this
Authority is mentioned back to them
again it's about the
consistency um and it also assists the
Fire Marshall to comply with recent
legislation it will Aid the fire
Marshall's office to accomplish the tax
task it was given by recent legislation
which is to catalog and list all local
city town and Municipal amendments on on
the brbc website which is the build and
code review board this bill will
accomplish this by effectively hitting
the reset button and allowing for a
fresh start for the process um this
amendment was a collaborative the
amendment was a collaborative effort
from many of the stakeholders and I hope
that this amendment will address their
concerns I will at this point conclude
my testimony and if you have any
questions I will try to answer them
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions yes representative leus
thank you and uh welcome Senator um so
first of all and I think I'm hoping the
answer to this is no but does this allow
and separate from the issue of the Gap
and what was done during the Gap does
this allow municipalities to make any
amendments to the building code that
were not you know they they can't do
under current law does it expand that in
any way no what this bill does is it
looks at that Gap period And basically
says no no no you shouldn't have done
that and make them go through this
process that was outlined in the
legislation that was signed but it
hadn't taken effect yet follow up follow
up okay and um the way I read it and
again I'm looking for
confirmation um a municipality could not
adopt a whole chunk of exist of building
code for example I don't know what the
Senate's going to do or if they've acted
on it but but we chose not to adopt the
uh the new um uh energy code and I mean
as I read it a municipality couldn't
decide on their own they were going to
do that is that correct under because
that original legislation is in effect
they can't do that okay
um they're they're in Edna now in on the
Senate side we're hearing that and we've
been getting a lot of email concerning
um that particular issue and I believe
an amendment is going to be presented to
US Senate Edna this morning all right
well that that's not on this bill but um
and and finally one final follow-up
follow you're referring to amendment I
assume that's the Senate amendment that
the Senate adopted okay thank
you yes representative Gard thank you
chairman just quick question something
you said that commercial buildings will
cost have cost more to ensure because
they weren't built to the current
building standards
yes so the responsibility is falling on
the state for that wouldn't that
oversight be to The Architects or the
the project managers I'm a little
confused okay thank you for the question
we have the Statewide building code
which sets a standard for how buildings
are supposed to be built here in New
Hampshire there's the the board which is
made up of people from all different
Industries and they actually go through
these things and under the system that
representative Maguire and I created
they go through them this and they come
up with what they want us to do because
prior to this we would get a code book
was like this thick and there was no way
that we could actually go through that
so we put the responsibility on them to
go through that and to then present um
updates to the legislation and
representative Maguire and I had thought
the best place to start would be in
house Edna you have more
members um you have subcommittees that
could go through this and look at it so
by the time we got it in the Senate
there might be a few tweaks here and
there but really the um the board I mean
we listen to the board and what their
suggestions are and we debate and
discuss what they're proposing did I
answer your question I might be wording
in correctly I yeah I'm just a little
confused that that operates but thank
you representative Le us if I could help
and this is I'm not sure uh I understand
what you're getting at but the question
would be um is there anything that would
prevent a business that wants the lower
Insurance to require that the building
be built to some newer or higher
building code thank you for the question
it's my understanding they could do that
on their own the state building CO code
is kind of like a skeleton or a floor I
mean a municipality can add but all that
original legislation just just said look
run it through the state uh the building
code review board and they're going to
take a look at it and then they're they
can say whoa whoa whoa you're you're
what you're doing doesn't even meet the
floor and ask them to go back and take a
look at it but if a municipality wants
to go beyond that all that legislation
said was we're going to look at it and
then we're going to send it back to you
and it was to really assist the fire
mark
in putting together these codes that
there be one place where anyone can go
any contractor developer to know in this
particular town this is what you have to
do because part of the problem was the
state there were so many different
places in the state that were doing
different things and developers
contractors it took them a long time to
be able to gather that information to
know well in I'm just going to use the
town of Epsom they have to do things
this way rather than the town of
londondary requires something
different so it's about it's about
conveying that
information thank
you any other questions yes
representative Gera you thank you um Mr
chair Senator Carson I just want some
clarification so what you had said was
there was that any municipality who had
taken advantage of that window mhm we
need to re would need to submit their
ordinances yeah the changes and it says
that any ordinance shall be submitted to
the State Building co-w I'm on page
three line 18 and 19 for review and
Confirmation is is that terminology sign
does that mean something to what does
that mean by well review but
confirmation
confirmation I'm I'm just trying to okay
figure out what the consequences will be
for those
municipalities who have used that
window and then they're they do submit
the information to the building code
review
board and then if the building I'm just
trying to find out what the consequences
will be for that community that the
municipality who took advantage of that
time thank you for that question um I
have not reviewed the original bill I
haven't gone back but um Mr Sherman is
here from the building code review board
and I think he could answer that um I
don't believe I put penalties in here um
it's just we're just saying
look send take those send them to the
building code review board and have them
take a look at it that's all thank you
so much thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much Senator thank you very much Mr
chairman William mckenny New Hampshire
building officials thank
you yes good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is William
mckenny I'm the president of the New
Hampshire building officials Association
we represent roughly 200 uh code
officials throughout the state we also
have membership from licens design
professionals such as Architects
engineers and as well as um contractors
around the state would you mind speaking
just a little bit closer to the mic I
can certainly do that thank you is that
better thank
you so Senate Bill 437 helps to clarify
and limit uh The Authority for local
communities to amend the State Building
Code and for that purpose nhpa supports
the bill um this helps to move um away
from uh when communities start to adopt
entire codes and really start to amend
the State Building Code it moves us away
from the intent the original intent of
155a RSA 155a which is the Statewide
building code and we start to end up
with pockets and islands of different
codes and if you recall prior to the
Statewide building code being adopted
that was the biggest concern from
developers was that you didn't know what
code you were working under depending
upon what community you were building in
and so RSA 155a was adopted to address
that issue in the state of mixed codes
all around so we should have one
Statewide building code it still
preserves the right for the communities
to adopt more stringent Provisions which
means as a code official you would need
to look at the code specifically dra
look at the section that you have a
concern with and propose an amendment to
that that may be more stringent than the
building code and then that would have
to be reviewed by the building code
review board this is a process that's
been adopted for several years now um
that were a few communities that um did
find a way that they could um put their
code amendments through um before uh an
effective date of the last legislation
and for that we support what is being
proposed here in s SB
437 we do have concerns however with um
page two from lines 28 through 37 and
page three lines 1 through 8 um as far
as is the
um
retroactive um effectiveness of some of
the provisions there such as if you have
adopted legal even through the legal
process have adopted that those um
amendments may basically become
ineffective it's a concern I I wouldn't
say it should be a deal breaker but it's
something that I think we should look at
and legally um make sure that you know
no Community can come through and file
suit against that so um with that uh I
would say that I would ask support um
from this committee for Senate Bill four
uh 437 and help close up some of the
loopholes that we currently have in our
uh
process with that I'll take any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions yes representative
Fitzpatrick I'm going to follow up on
what representative groa was uh brought
up with the previous uh speaker
on page three lines four and five upon
withholding of confirmation of a
submitted local amendment by the State
Fire Marshall local amendments shall not
be
enforced what does that mean that would
be the specific language that you know
members of our association are concerned
with um that that also shows up under
the building code um uh piece of it as
well um so what that would say is that
um any any if for some reason the
building code review board finds that
anything that was adopted even if it's
through the legal process um doesn't
comply with this RSA then you could no
longer enforce that and I think that's
opens the door to a legal battle that I
I I don't have enough knowledge about
followup followup because enforced by
who by State Fire Marshal by the local
building codes
it it would not be enforceable by the
local
community further followup and and would
probably also lead to uh AUD
adjud adjudication uh by uh developers
and and it could just be a mess it seems
to me again that that particular section
of this does cause us some concern the
rest of the bill is well
crafted thank you you're welcome
representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman so was
this issue already raised in the
senate representative F Patrick's
question yes sir it was it was uh raised
in the in the one of the hearings at the
Senate and and again it's here I can't
speak to the to the legal
um results of that but I I would say
that you know some of those communities
that have adopted through the process
that was
available to them may question the um
being able to have retroactive action so
is this bill going to Senate
subcommittee I'm I'm sorry I I'm sorry
I'm late the Senate was working on I
just barely got out of the Senate uh if
it's do you think it should go to sub
commmittee
um maybe we should hear from everybody
else first to see if it gets cleared up
by but yes but I know that Mr McKinley
will work with the subcommittee if there
is one I mean I I if this isue has
already been raised a senate has made a
decision uh then we certainly have to
look at whether we think this is a
workable situation or a good solution or
whatever and I chairman Sherman is
probably going to testify on this is he
got a carded he does yeah that's what
I'm saying maybe we just exp we hear
everybody out and then we'll make a call
from there exactly thank you Mr
chairman yes representative Mani thank
you Mr chair uh thank you for taking my
question isn't this totally opposite of
uh what New Hampshire does usually the
local control is very um top priority
and so in this particular instance the
take local control is taken away and
state controls it so is that normal or
not thank you that's a very good
question uh I don't believe local
control is being taken away at this I
believe it is limiting what the locals
local communities can do to you know
massage the State Building Code um RSA
155 a when it was adopted and I believe
was early
2000s had the limit in that that the
communities could adopt more stringent
provisions of the State Building Code or
or adopted codes it never had the intent
or never had the language in it that you
could adopt an entire
code um communities have gone through
and adopted entire codes and then put in
the provisions there in Provisions in
their ordinance that says oh unless the
state building code is more restrictive
than you have to follow the State
Building Code knowing that there may be
Provisions in the code that they've
adopted that are less stringent than the
state code so what this does is prevents
communities from adopting an entire book
of code
without going through the process of
vetting that code to make sure that
there's nothing in there that's less
stringent than the state
code followup a followup so you're just
confirming my confusion as to if it is
Le if the local communities adopt a less
strting stringent code than State that's
not allowed but if they are local
communities are adopting more stringent
than the state it is
okay again I believe this bill brings it
brings back RSA 15's original intent is
that you would need to adopt line by
line provisions of the code that you
would like to have more
stringent representative Brown uh thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so going going back a little
bit to where you were on page two line
26 to 37 or let's say line 26
to35 the the first part on line 26 27
28 so now I understand what I didn't
understand the times I've read this at
home I believe that that prior to July
2024 n RSA 155 is that Gap that the
senator was speaking of correct yes sir
thank you and then going down to line 33
to 35 it has that same language that uh
representative Fitzpatrick mentioned on
the next page line 30 3 to 35 is for the
building code changes whereas on page
three it's for changes to the fire
code is that correct that is correct sir
thank you
and would it make sense that when it
says shall not be enforced that would
not follow the normal enforcement
processes of of the local
body again there are at least two
communities I believe that follow the
legal process that was in effect at the
time and the question would be and and
maybe it just needs clarification from
you know the legal experts here in
conquered of whether
retroactively not allowing them to
enforce that if they had adopted that
prior to July 1
2024 um if that's legal or not and that
is our only concern and I believe it it
affects truthfully two communities in
the state okay thank
you any further questions
yes representative
goalie thank you Mr chair do we know
what those two communities
are excuse
me Durham what are the two communities
the two communities that would be of
concern would be Durham and
Portsmith see excuse me
represent Mr Greenland if you could get
with our legal team and find out what is
with that issue
thank
you seeing no further questions thank
you for your testimony I would if I
could sir I'd like to express
representative gard's uh question about
insurance and insurance ratings that he
asked um Senator
Carson um maybe if you could do it
afterwards with him individually that
that would probably be better absolutely
thank you all right I thank you for your
time uh Gary Abbot associate general
contractors
uh thank you chairman committee members
for the record my name is Gary Abbott
I'm the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I represent commercial and
Industrial uh contractors subcontractors
and suppliers I'm here today today in
support of Senate Bill
437 I was here years before when we
supported the original legislation that
talked about filing
amendments there really is two major
benefits for my industry with this bill
and the
clarification what this bill is just Rec
clarifying uh that when municipalities
make amendments to the code it gets
filed with the building code review
board they revie view it to make sure
it's not in Conflict which is great for
us that it gets filed and therefore is
an easy resource for the industry to go
there and look at what the differences
are with specific cities and towns now
when the first legislation drafted
this there becomes some unclarity of how
this would work in totality and many
communities didn't file so the resource
right now for us is not totally there
not all the community are particip
participating in filing their
amendments now I will tell you the the
other issue for us is I'm still
mystified I was around back when we
adopted the Statewide building codes so
we went from towns having their own
building codes to the state and the
reason for that is most towns were
behind in the code and the industry and
others were saying we can't be 10 years
back in a code so the codes got moved up
today it's I find it very interesting
that we're talking about towns who go
beyond uh the code when in fact like
right now we're about to adopt the 21
code so the Amendments that have been
filed are against the 2018 code well
guess what those amendments aren't going
to work for town when we adopt the 21
code if they amended the 18 because the
21 language is going to be different so
there's a lot of work for cities and
towns to do to make sure their
amendments match and I think this bill
tries to clarify some of that because
some of those amendments may not make
sense anymore because they don't match
up with the new 21 code that we're
adopting so I I want to put that on the
table I really towns are putting
themselves through a lot of work to
amend a code that with are being one
cycle back doesn't make a lot of sense
to me but if a town does it this bill
kind of outlines that process that they
go to the building code review board and
here comes the second most important for
us
we wanted to reduce the number of future
Municipal Code conflicts that's where we
get into trouble we try to build a
building and you have a municipal code
that's different than the State Building
Code and we end up in a a mess trying to
build a project so that's the second
reason we really like this bill is it
tries to do that we're getting on track
the chairman and others and Senator
Carson over the years have done a great
job of getting this building code in the
adoption of amendments the adoption of
the code being one year behind I think
this puts structure to those local
amendments to be filed and again we're
not saying the town can't do this or
can't adopt a a an individual Amendment
to the code the problem is is in one
section you're gonna you're probably
going to highlight adopting completely
different codes and whatever it could be
that would be a huge conf for us because
it doesn't match it completely takes out
what everybody's trained to do so this
bill tries to put in guard rails and I
put it as guard rails to keep everybody
moving in the same direction and then we
work on the next code in the building
code review board and the experts work
on it so I think this bill it may be a
little fuzzy things now but it's nowhere
near how fuzzy the one we had already
passed this bill clears up a lot and
sets in the guard rails for the future
so we're here in total support of this
new language that helps give it
guidelines for cities and towns because
the other issue that this addresses if
it's filed we know it is a legally
approved amendment by the town we don't
want somebody just changing a building
code that hasn't gone through the
process with the town to get it legal
and then get it filed when it goes to
the the state so there is a couple of
things that this does for us so we're
here in total support of this amendment
that you've got and uh we appreciate and
like to have you guys ought to pass
thank you very much thank you very much
any questions uh yeah representative
schmi and then
[Music]
Fitzpatrick thank you Mr chairman so you
heard Bill McKenna just now talk about
his issues uh I'm sure that's not
something you never heard of before
so what's your position on his
reservations well I I think his
reservations are and this is just I
don't want to offend him at all but it's
it's more on the minor side of you know
what happens when your amendment is no
longer matching up with what the new
code is I think that's where it's
putting in language to
say that Amendment doesn't apply anymore
it's got to go away somehow and uh I
think that's what's in here it's not in
intended to go away like we're ignoring
it but it has to go away in some process
and I don't think this is the end all I
I imagine in the future you're going to
deal with some of those issues as we get
more clarity but I think this is a great
step
forward so if if it goes to the
subcommittee as it may you're going to
be you guys going to be available to
help us work this out sure thank you
representative Fitzpatrick thank you m
Mr chair um just to uh clarify I'm 100%
in favor of Statewide building codes and
I could even be Co convinced that that
local governments don't have the ability
to adopt anything more more stringent
but I'm having a very difficult time
being told that uh local local
governments can adopt a building codes
more uh more AR stringent when I'm
reading again on uh page page three
lines four and five and six that uh
local governments don't have that
ability so could you help me und
understand what I'm not
seeing I guess I would prefer the two
experts that are in the room okay so you
can't answer that question yeah I would
prefer to you know the whole Enforcement
issue from the Fire Marshall and the
other it might be appropriate with those
answering the question okay thank
you yes representative man py thank you
Mr chair with regards to building codes
for multifam with the housing crisis
more like 150 to 100 units that would be
more commercial correct so how does that
impact if the building codes that the
state laid out is is 3 to four years
behind we are adopting just now 2021 we
are in
2024 well well there's rule when you get
into codes there's rules like when it
becomes effective in a grace period for
those that are in the process of
developing those large projects to get
it approved and going so they don't have
to make the adjustment to the latest
code but at the same time most
contractors of they know when these
codes are coming they they know they
know through guys like me that we're
updating the codes to the 21 code I I
hadn't finished my question in terms of
how would it impact not just the
insurance but also financing investor
financing if the basic code is not
available in a state for example cpce is
not available then the funding which can
cover 30 to 40% of a large building will
not come in to the state to provide the
investment so how would that offset or
is there a provision for developers to
uh meet that I I guess what I would I
don't think this bill does anything
regarding that this really deals with
just amendments by the municipality to
the state Wide building code it doesn't
really go
into the code change and the financial
impact I think that's I think that's
fair any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you Philip Sherman building code review
board now that we're on 437 not
599 thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Philip chairman the chair of the
building code review board speak in
support of SP 437 as amended um I have
some prepared remarks and then I can
cover some of the questions that are are
sort of outstanding here uh so first
local governments have been required to
provide their local
amendments uh to the building code
review board for posting on the website
for a long time now a total of five
municipalities have done so we have a
problem here
uh the requirement to submit all code
amendments and their enabling ordinances
for review does not raise the bar for
any amendments this is information that
was supposed to be submitted in the past
anyway the additional prohibition on
adopting later additions of the model
codes included in the State Building
Code attempts to resurrect the original
intent that the State Building Code
would apply Statewide with limited
amendments but not that entire code
codes would be replaced by the
municipality we can't have it both ways
either we have a Statewide building code
or we pretty much go back to a Time
prior to 2002 where every town and city
does whatever they
want having multiple codes in effect is
problematic at a number of levels
electricians plumbers gas Fitters and
others answer to licensing boards and
the continuing education requirements
based on the State Building code
training for building officials is
provided based on the current State
Building Code frequently local code
adoption and perhaps the amendment
process are driven by one or more
forceful individuals at a single point
in time then voted on by a small subset
of the people impacted by the code
because obviously only residents of that
town are voting on
it this bypasses the more democratic
process at the state level involving all
interested groups the bcrb the
legislature and ultimately the
governor the proposed amendment would
make existing ordinances adopting later
additions of the model codes invalid and
makes it clear that adopting most or all
of a new code through multiple
amendments hand us 500 amendments to get
to a new code is not permitted so the
existing language is ambiguous it
basically says says to something to the
effect that municipalities can adopt
codes that are not in the State Building
Code the reason that that's there and it
and it remains is to permit the adoption
of housing codes Property Maintenance
codes and things like that which many of
the at least of the larger cities have
done and that's not the problem here the
problem is adopting later additions of
the codes that are in fact in the State
Building Code so this proposed amend
proposed bill as amended
tries to correct two long-standing
problems with the local amendment
process one as previously testified the
lack of an ability to have a cohesive
location in other words our website
where somebody can say here are all the
local amendments that apply and two this
issue of adopting later additions of the
model codes which basically deletes the
idea of a Statewide building code happy
to answer any
questions thank you representative us
thank you um don't want to get into
detail on this here but could you send a
link to uh if you have it to at least
the uh Municipal amendments or updates
the building code um at least the ones
you've been informed of as you should be
I'd like to get a feel for what kind of
uh things the uh municipalities are
actually trying to do I will be happy to
work with the State Fire Marshall in
that our website just got restrung to a
new system and I'm still coming up to
speed on where various things are I'll
find it for you all right thank you
represent fuk then thank you is the
intent of this
bill
to only make uh local uh changes
enforceable if they go through the
process of the of the
submission and let me and but in other
words they're not enforced they won't be
enforced if they're not submitted to uh
the office to be re reviewed and
commented on but if they are then they
are in enforceable this what I'm trying
to understand this and please let let me
see if I can can parse that out first
there was a question about review and
Confirmation those were carefully worked
out terms when we did the original uh
have the bcrb review these prior to that
all they had to do was send them in we
didn't even read them just post them but
nobody did that so as of I think January
of
23 we started to review and confirm
these the reason that those words were
used is we have absolutely nothing to
say about the technical validity of any
of these amendments all we're looking
for is to be sure one one that they were
legally adopted through whatever
ordinance process applies and two that
they're more stringent than the state
code or they not less stringent and
three that they don't conflict with the
fire code by simply reviewing it with
the State Fire Marshal so if somebody
wants to you know tell you you need a 20
foot high ceiling in this room that's
not what we're looking at all we're
saying is the code says 76 you say 20
check on you go have a legal ordinance
it doesn't conflict with the fire code
that's all we've done um furthermore
there are three main areas that we don't
even look at and that's permitting
process fee structures and certificates
of occupancy so those for many years
have been reserved for the Loca
municipalities and we defined the uh our
review ordinance the part of 155a and
67451 to eliminate those so you don't
have to send them to us um so basic
if the city of Nashua adopted a legal
ordinance all they do is just send us
the link and they're done it's legal
it's there we'll take a quick peek at it
yep it's more stringent or nope it
doesn't apply and then they're finished
so nobody is coming back and saying that
a legally adopted ordinance is no longer
valid I think just for clarification on
that there in your example State
Building Code says 7 and2 ft Portsmouth
wants it to be 20t if they don't submit
that to you in the process can they
enforce that can they still enforce the
20 that's what this bill is trying to do
is to force them to submit it for two
reasons one to check the the issues and
two to provide this list of local
amendments on the website so people know
what they've got to got to deal with so
if this were to pass it would not be
enforcable until they came to
you if they have a legal ordinance all
they have to do is send us to us within
60 days and they're done then we'll look
at it and provided it was
legal no no mus no fuss uh thank you I
all right I understand what you're what
you're doing now thank you uh I support
it but I do think that this uh bill
needs some clarification and it's
wording thank you representative meny
and then representative L thank you Mr
chair so you
mentioned uh something with the five
commune municipalities ities have
adopted or submitted Amendment out of
280 some municipalities in state of New
Hampshire was this the amendment to the
code that building state code that they
wanted to amend or what was in relation
I didn't quite get your point on that so
there are 200 and some odd
municipalities somewhere around half of
those enforc the Statewide building code
the others Statewide code applies but
the towns are not enforcing it so they
don't have any amendments because
they're not enforcing It Anyway of the
towns that towns and cities that do have
amendments uh we don't know how many
there were we only know that five of
them have sent it to us so it's this
it's this old requirement just to send
them for posting that isn't even wasn't
even being complied with and we know
that there are many more than five who
have amendments because we can go on the
website and look at them represent m y
thank you so follow up to that is this
bill clarifying that if they haven't
submitted there's an amendment there's a
penalty or enforcement that they have to
submit is their provision on this this
this basically forces them to send it to
us it just recycles that process because
so many of the municipalities were not
not following anyway this forces them to
send it to us or they can't enforce the
thing representative leus thank you um
so a number of times you're talking
about a legal ordinance does the for it
to be legal does that mean that it's met
those three things that you said you
review or is it does it mean something
else we became aware uh within the last
month or so of a town that was using
their zoning board of appeals as the
building code review or building code
appeal F board and never had an
ordinance to do that we're much aware of
local officials over time a little less
of it now just saying this is what I
want in my town so the whole process was
intended to say this has to be done
through an ordinance that or you know
the appropriate legal process to adopt
these follow up follow up um so it it's
a legal process even if it let's say is
less stringent the existing building
code or tries to replace the whole code
or the other thing there was another
well no that was it um cuz you said that
if they submit it to you within 16 days
as long as it's a legal ordinance which
from what you just said would mean that
it's been adopted through some legal
process that they can then enforce it
but the bill I think says that it has to
be confirmed let's say there was an
ordinance adopted that that provided for
a requirement that was less stringent
than the building code was never legal
in the first place okay all right thank
you representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman so I think
we're all I think we we're all concerned
about situations where uh a lack of
Standards puts people at risk but aren't
the building code officials and and uh
like the general
contractors those those people Al also
have ethical responsibilities don't they
so that in the smaller towns where they
don't have the necessary
infrastructure regulation wise and so
forth to oversee it where it's
potentially
the excuse me the silman's
brother-in-law who uh is maybe building
things and so forth where you get
sloppiness or or failure to comply with
safety standards and so forth but but
aren't we somewhat protected because the
contractors also are supposed to be
adhering to
codes yes somewhat somewhat but sounds
like we're getting more organized and
that's a good
thing any other questions I have just
one for clarification if you could
clarify something that was spoken before
um if we were to pass this the governor
was to sign it um ironically it would
probably be about 60 days in between his
signing and when it actually takes
effect before um would this
make that window that occurred before
would it make those codes those uh
Municipal codes obsolete would they have
to change them anyway to meet the new
code AS was stated
earlier you have to look at two parts of
this uh the permitting the fees the
certificate of occupancy the board of
appeals kind of stuff that's reserved
for the locals probably not because
those while they override some of the
stuff that's in the model codes it's
clearly reserved for the locals and and
we don't have a lot of problems with
that on the technical side uh an
amendment is to a code almost by
definition so once that code is no
longer in effect you need a new
amendment is that is that understood
between the the localities and the state
though that they would have to do that I
can tell tell you that in my cursory
review of a few websites have found
major cities in the state where websites
and presumably ordinances had not been
adopt not been updated even to reflect
the current State Building Code these
things take on a lot of energy and then
they go to sleep and people tend to
forget about
them so I guess my final question in
that train of thought then is this would
require any new amendments to come to
you
does it State anything about updating
old amendments and having those come to
you every time the building code is
renewed the the statute as it sits today
requires new amendments to come to us
that that's since January of
23 um I'm having difficulty
understanding an amendment that would
carry from one addition of a code to the
next because an amendment is an
amendment to a version of a code right I
I agree with you 100% on that I'm I'm
saying do the localities know that do
they know that it doesn't transfer so
they make an amendment to the 2018 code
and then we move to the 2021 does the
locality know that their Amendment to
the 2018 is now Obsolete and they'll
have to update it you're used to this
because you have to do it every couple
of years municipalities may not be as
familiar with the with the process do
they know to do that and is there a way
to hold them accountable to doing that
the the build officials Association does
a wonderful job at education for the
people that are within their their view
uh I can't say that everybody gets to
that
education uh and I'm not really familiar
with how towns become aware of New rsas
U whether they read them or not okay
thank you very much Mr shman thank you
Sean
timy
morning again Sean tum many State Fire
Marshal for the record I was trying to
hide back there but the State Fire
Marshall came up a few times so I should
probably figured it should come up um
quick so we have four communities that I
just brought it up four communities that
are currently listed Portsmouth
Manchester Durham and Amherst um Port
Smith adopted the fully adopted a later
addition of the electrical code which
has created some conflicts between our
adopted currently adopted state
electrical code and portsmiths which is
um created some challenges for
electricians um Durham as we know
adopted the later addition of the energy
code um Manchester in their building
code uh it's mostly are some procedural
stuff and like for the helping to
identify what the snow load or the wind
load or the seismic requirements are
which I think is helpful information and
that's what their Amendment largely does
that those typ to things Amherst um just
a quick review I'm not didn't go through
the full documents but talks about some
water well testing and PFA and P you
know p and those types of things try to
clarify so not huge types of items um
I'm going to say in general the Fire
Marshals office and Department of Safety
is neutral on the bill I think it's uh
you know it's up to the general court as
how how we want to restrict local
communities on the the scope of uh the
what they can and cannot do with the
codes um
the you know I think we're really
talking about two communities as we
already talked about that have gone way
above and beyond uh the the small
changes I I think work well the my
office where you've come up the
questions come up in the past my office
has been asked for the building code
review board and the board of Fire
Control to sort of catalog those so
we're trying to create and the ask was
from the general court create a One-Stop
shop so anyone in the state whether
you're a homeowner a developer or a
design firm can find this is the state
fire code these are the state amendments
and oh by the way this is where I find
the local amendments whether you're
talking about the building code or fire
code and we've been trying very hard
over the last couple years to try to
pull that together and frankly it's like
a hide and seek game for us and I think
that
um I I think this uh statute or the
proposed uh revision and Bill would help
clean up some of that stuff and try to
really achieve what we're after is try
to help simplify process codes are
difficult and it's anyways and if we can
help make it easier for the end users um
I think that's a win happy to be part of
a conversation on subcommittee try to
figure out how to navigate and make it
better um but I think everyone that's
sitting here today is is really trying
to make it a little bit better um and
the process a little bit smoother and
that's what we've been trying to work
for for I would say the last six years
that I've been involved with um so happy
to try to answer questions just want to
try to help frame that a little bit so
sorry one quick thing the enforcement
side um probably every other week we get
a phone call sometimes on the building
code definitely on the fire code side of
um a Fire official wanting that wanting
to like I want to enforce something I
want I want smoke alarms to be smoking
carbon monoxide alarms and have no Rhyme
or Reason to do that and they want to
enforce that I think the enforcement
side of you you can't enforce madeup
stuff unless it's gone through the local
process and then we just do a quick
check to say is it conflicting with the
State Fire Cod not and similarly on the
building code side so um it's not trying
to be a stronghold it's just like trying
to I think trying to make it easier for
the end user that's that's how I keep
coming back to in my head so sorry I
think I'm done fine thank you any
questions seeing none thank you Mr thank
you Stephen B
Court
electricians morning Mr chairman and
committee members my name is Steven
rancot I'm uh a liced electrician in the
state of of Hampshire and also here
representing the ecba electrical
contractors Business Association um let
me start off if I could by saying that
there's a lot of time and effort put
into this bill to try to come up with
the right wording with all the
interested parties or most of them if
possible we did we didn't just you know
come up with it we tried to see how it
affected it as Senator Carson um
mentioned it cleans up the bill because
it was mentioned what their Authority
was in so many different spots through
the rsas that there's always different
interpretation this trying clarifies it
and references to it to try to make it
um
easier um the a lot of the towns as far
as uh one of the questions that came up
was the um how would the towns know
about it in uh and talking to Bill
mckenny he mentioned that the New
Hampshire Municipal Association is
usually where the municipalities get
their information and that the New
Hampshire building officials would be
glad to provide that updated information
to them so they could get it so that's
typically how they they get their
information so um that just to answer
that question the other one of the other
issues was it talked about the date so
it talks about July 1st 2024 I think on
page two line
27 and that was meant to try to give the
fire marshal to get this on the website
a reset like you said everybody even
those who have submitted before they
don't have to go through the legal
process again they just have to resubmit
it because it has to follow what's been
an existing law I think that's probably
the most important thing that this law
exists already and we find is many or
quite a few towns municipalities aren't
aware of this we we had a meeting
probably eight years ago back when a
previous Fire Marshal everybody was
there a big thing and it was brought to
our attention by the legal councel from
the municipalities that this is the
process they're supposed to follow
nobody really knew that so we're only
trying to one make sure they're
following the legal process a lot of
them don't even know that they don't
even know the legal process it has to go
through a vote through the
town like like any situation some you
know there's
no um there's no requirements for
inspectors in town in states in the
municipalities while many of them are
qualified but there's a lot of them as
you get to you know outskirts in the
smaller towns and cities that it's you
know they they have volunteer people
help and and sometimes you know they'll
take an put an amendment in or something
they require because that's what they
want and they don't follow the legal
process to make it happen we're just
asking the follow that we have to follow
the law I would think you would want the
municipalities to follow the law in
putting these amendments forward they
you know we've all heard of it I'm sure
but I had one situation one town where I
he required he asked me to do a certain
thing for grounding I showed him the
codebook where it said I did it proper I
talked to the state inspector to NFPA
representative and multiple people very
high in the industry they all said I was
correct and then he finally said well
that's what I want that makes it very
tough for us right I mean honestly it's
just you know we just want like I said
if it's on the website the State
Building Code website and it's listed
there and we go and we have to bid a job
or do something we can say oh this town
requires this okay this town requires
this so it does make it easier it helps
make it more efficient and just stops
you know um it from being just what they
may want in that particular town for no
particular reason
um the
uh yeah so this is just requiring exist
this is just clearing up that
requirement that they have to do to put
forth an amendment in the town itself
and trying to give it some sort of
oversight with some technical expertise
at the state billing code board
sometimes these inspectors might put
them through or the billing officials in
the town don't have anywhere near the
amount of experience that the state
billing code board has and it gives a
look over to make sure it's not
conflicting not less stringent than and
then from there the confirmation process
is if you're going to put in a code and
you're going to say this is what I want
and I have to do
that everybody was concerned about um
unless it's um confirmed shall not be
enforced well that wording was put in
there for just that example okay so this
person decides that's what they want but
they didn't go through the legal process
so now I have to follow something that
hasn't been done legally that would be
like me saying well I think it should be
85 miles an hour in the highway so I'm
just going to go that speed you know I
the law is there tells them the process
to adopt it and if they haven't gone
through that why should I have to follow
their their requirement once they've
gone through the legal process no
problem so it's trying to clarify that
as well
um it it creates a Level Playing Field
for everybody and it it makes it so that
you know what town wants what when it's
been adopted all these the what Senator
um Carson spoke about was for years we
went through and Tred to correct this
issue and and make it something that was
workable for everybody and we basically
they were years behind with the
insurance concern with on the codes and
this brought it up to basically the
codes try to stay one cycle behind now
they're in the process of trying to
adopt those other ones but that one
cycle just for instance for us we had
issues that came up and there were I
think 14 um temporary amendments to like
Massachusetts let's just say just to
give an example for our electrical code
because one of the things they required
the manufacturers didn't even make they
were having problems with split systems
everywhere that required ground fall
potenti protction anything 250 Volt or
more and it was causing issues
everywhere and they had to stop it so we
kind of let them go through that problem
by one cycle behind they fix those
things because and then when we adopt
the code that one cycle behind you know
about the issues you're either able to
address them or not or they've already
taken care of them from the manufacturer
standpoint so that one code cycle behind
is very important to let that happen
because a lot of times these codes in
our situation manufacturers who go to
the code make panels and they try to
that's how they sell product right we're
going to we're going to make you acquire
Arc faults or ground faults or you know
T you know tamperproof Outlet so this
just helps to let those work themselves
out if there's no process and stay that
one cycle behind so I hope that the
committee would vote in favor of this
there was a lot of time and effort put
into it try to make the wording we can
definitely make sure that it doesn't
cause an issue with Shell Con form but
that Shell Con form is just saying hey
if you didn't follow the process then
you shouldn't be able to enforce it I
would think that the entire committee
agrees if you don't follow the law you
shouldn't be able to make somebody do
something so that's where that comes
from and I'll take any questions if need
thank you for your time thank you for
your testimony any
questions representa Gart thank you
chairman very quickly is there any
liability for a building inspector that
goes off the reservation and starts
making up things you can go through the
legal process which is very expensive to
show that you didn't have to follow that
but I mean but it's not yeah it's not
easily this gives you that kind of some
sort of
Statewide you know process to make sure
that for us if we go to the town too not
to we can I can go to a town and they
say hey I want this I just go on to the
website I look it up on on the bi Marsh
website and I can see if they posted
their Amendment so it tells me when I'm
getting a permit if this town has
actually followed the process if it's
not there then at least I know I have a
I can have a discussion with them about
it
thank any other questions seeing none
thank you very much for your testimony
is there anybody else who wishes to
speak on SP 437
the chair gave me the gavel for two
bills and we're 16 minutes behind seeing
none I will close the public hearing and
hand the gavel
off all right thank you I'm opening the
public hearing on Senate Bill 367 and I
call senator
bson
good
morning uh for the record my name is
Regina berzel I'm the state senator for
district 19 which encompasses the towns
of um Dairy Hamstead and Windham and I'm
here as the prime sponsor of Senate Bill
367 um Senate Bill 367 is a continuation
of the um PTSD commission that we've
that I've been chairing for probably the
last um four maybe five years if not
more longer than that um we've had some
pretty recent uh accomplishments um as
we put a subcommittee together to um put
some to start in looking at some
standards for what we call the Comfort
dogs you I'm sure you're aware of
Liberty from conquered and um Patches
from Manchester
um apparently there's a um there is no
standard in nowhere in um the United
States do they have a standard for
Comfort dogs um and New Hampshire is
looking to be one of the first ones
we've brought on uh on the subcommittee
is the owner of hero pups uh Laura
Barker um and the Manchester police
department and Laura Barker she
typically um she does all the training
and the breeding of the dogs that some
of these Comfort dogs are used so um
we're trying to get um some standards
put together so they're not confused
with some of the Comfort dogs the
general Comfort dogs that people use on
on um planes and and things such as that
um we also put in uh training a
requirement for training on PTSD for our
First Responders which include the um
which would include new hires um and
continuing uh education during their uh
during the lifetime of their career and
also at retirement and after retirement
because a lot of uh lot what we find um
during that commission we found that a
lot of the First Responders after they
retire is where PTSD really kind of kick
sometimes kicks in and that's where a
lot of the suicides happen so um we put
that some of the earlier accomplishments
we've done is we put in a presumption
for PTSD uh we also uh put in uh author
we as put in a bill to allow life
insurance for families of First
Responders who do commit
suicide and also the commission has
brought to light some seminars on mental
health and
resiliency excuse me to help change the
culture of leadership because we what we
what when we first started
the um the commission we found that
there were some uh standard that
leadership wasn't um paying attention to
uh the results of PTSD in their in their
um in their employees so the commission
has put to brought to light some of
these issues and um there are some
Mental Health Providers along with um
the firefighters have put together these
seminars which bring the leadership of
our First Responders
into um train them train them to see
some of the um PTSD signs
um our Target for this next commission
um as you can see in the duties um we
want to put some options for
streamlining workers compensation
process in order to avoid
retraumatization of First Responders
with PTSD so what happens is a lot of
times when a first responder goes into
to try and
um claim workers comp claim for a uh
PTSD um episode uh what happens is we
found that they are made to interview
numerous times throughout the
process um thereby compounding the issue
so what we're going to be looking at is
trying to allow them to testify once in
front of a number of people um so that
they can um um so they won't be
continually having to tell their story
on a consistent basis um we're
also I my plan is within the next two
years is to make sure that we do have um
comfort dog standards the the commiss
the committee is uh hopefully doing
their work now within the next two years
we should have some standards or within
the next year I'm hoping to have some
standards on these Comfort dogs um in
addition the other thing we want to
study is
um one thing we found when we were in
the commission there's a lot there's not
a lot of data on how many suicides um
are First Responders and one of the one
of the black holes is when when you're
we did find that Funeral Directors
actually do have a lot of the
information but what they don't have is
information from let's say First
Responders um part-time volunteers so we
don't have a lot of data on Vol um the
volunteer and part- timers so uh we've
talked with the funeral directors we
want to start looking into that and find
out what we need to do to allow the
funeral directors to start um tracking
that information so we have better data
um as far as the PTSD committed uh
suicides so with that I'll try and
entertain any questions I know there's a
number of people that would like to
speak as well yes I have a a question
question you said that you have you
instituted PTSD training for First
Responders how did you how did you do
that in rules no we actually put bills
in okay so so you are submitting putting
most of this into statute yep thank
you representative
Shu thank you madam chair um good
morning Senator thank you for taking my
question you mentioned uh the importance
of data um but in the commission's
duties I don't see a reference to
collecting data would would you
uh that would
[Music]
um so number three on page two um under
Roman numeral 2 the addition of
part-time volunteer first responder to a
funeral director death certificate drop
down menu that's part of where we're um
trying to find the
data okay so you're you would recommend
getting data from other sources not uh
the state creating
data well no what what we're looking to
do is find out what we need to do
because what the funeral directors we're
really directing at the funeral
directors um because what they do is
typically they have a drop- down menu
and um they can choose whether it's a
firefighter uh but they don't have the
different a full-time part-time
volunteer so we want us look into how we
go go ahead and have I think it comes
from the
archives um the Secretary of State's
office so we want to figure out how we
can get that information into the
funeral director's drop down menu so
that they can start targeting that and
that'll generate a question from the
funeral director to the family um was
your um loved one uh first responder um
if he was was he or she was she a um uh
part-time full-time volunteer so we can
start extrapolating some of that data
thank you representative Gart and then
representative goalie thank you madam
chair as far as standards go for the
comfort dogs is there has there been an
issue of them not comforting correct I'm
a little confused as to what the the
problem would be why would you need a
standard for for those dogs because
these are Public public owned um dogs
basically and a lot of times what
happens is they get
confused the these Comfort dogs get
confused and are have a lot more
training than let's say a dog that would
a comfort dog that would um company you
want a on a plane so we want to make
sure that even if we're the first ones
in the US to be because a lot of states
have comfort dogs but there are no there
are no um
regulations um and standards and we want
to be one of the first ones to do that
but they go through rigorous training
where a lot of the other dogs do not so
we want to make sure that if you're
considered a public Comfort dog you have
the right
training okay thank you
goie thank you thank Madam chair and
thank you senator for uh the work you're
doing on this commission and uh the
commitment you're putting forward with
it um just a quick question on I see
there's a large group of individuals
listed to this are they all
participating at this time with we have
had a really good um it's a kind of a
well-oiled machine because we've been
working together for for a number of
years and there's a lot of knowledge on
it so yeah they typically everyone shows
up thank you okay thank
you represent lus thank you so um is the
existing commission going away or is
this intended to change something about
the current one or well the by law we
only extended out for two years we're
now kind of um in limbo we're waiting
for this one to be extended so we can
all get back together again thank
you okay Simon thank you mam chair
Senator thank you for taking question
just for clarification so has the
commission lapsed like has there been a
twoyear gap or just like a short Gap in
between you finished up your first set
of work and now you want to start up in
your next one I believe when our final
report was due in November that um I
think October was our last meeting Okay
so we've we've we've had to lapse
because we had no authorization to meet
great thank you okay other
questions thank you very much thank you
have a
approve
representative Mark PR Hillsboro 15 uh
thank you for letting me speak I'll make
it quick um I was on the commission uh
years ago then I didn't run one term
last term um but I did actually go to
the commission meetings because I felt
it was very important I've been involved
in critical instance Stress Management
which is pretty much the prevention of
PTSD or trying to do that with a team
state run team uh and I know this
commission has up the standard for the
teams in the state um and to the uh
Comfort dog there is specific training
for the dogs that work with Public
Safety and we want to make sure they
meet that requirement when they're
working with us
so
um gathering
information putting it out doing
training for First Responders first time
ever became mandatory for firefighters
that they actually had to sit and watch
the the training right and get signed
off so
awareness is a big part of what we all
do um so I I do believe this commission
is very important and still has a lot of
work to do because um unfortunately
police fire and EMS are committing
suicide at a higher rate than joq public
and almost as much as the veterans so we
have a lot of work still to do and I
hope you support us and I'll take any
questions I don't see any thank you very
much representative Brown sorry we we
can I was a little slow there thank you
madam shair um would you so what is I I
understand a comfort dog well could you
explain that a little bit for me how's
that if I maybe I don't understand it
that that and to be honest I don't
understand it all very well myself I
just know that there is certain training
for Comfort dogs that work with
PTSD as opposed to um grandma in the
nursing home that they just come around
and and you can Pat the dog and and that
makes you feel better as opposed to the
Comfort dog that can sense that this
guy's stressed and goes up to them
they'll pick you right out of a crowd
and walk up to you and yeah just patting
the dog and the dog being able to
understand what's going on with that
person to a point uh and and providing
you know that care and it truly is care
right perfect thank
you man py thank you Madame chair so
this is not a personal dog like or
diabetes or uh autism where you know you
have uh no seizure dogs that sense the
aura this is a firefighter will be
taking a dog into a crowd or into public
and they will be sensing
another individual in public that might
be stress and that might be
contemplating soci so there
are two different categories and both of
those are are the categories right
because uh you seen veterans and I
actually know a couple of firefighters
that have their own Comfort dog that go
with them everywhere uh one of the
things that my team does is what we call
a debriefing right we get everybody
involved in the incident we sit around
in a in a circle and we discuss a call
and and do some things and a dog will
come in and walk the
circle right and maybe sit down in front
of somebody for a little bit they get to
Pat them while other people are talking
uh and once the dog kind of senses that
that guy's a little bit better because
as you're talking about the incident
you're going to bring up those emotions
again uh and for some people it's pretty
significant and the dog will go right
over and and and it takes away that
stress it's amazing to
watch I'm sh it thank you madam chair um
are thank you for taking my question do
you foresee that these dogs would for
example be able to Intuit someone who is
in
stress um because that followup that to
me would be more a designation as a
service dog Comfort dogs usually do
apply to dogs that go into hospitals and
just provide comp it I think that's
something that we can discuss when
they've got their outline of what the
rules are oh I just wanted to establish
what what they felt the dog was supposed
to do so uh like I said I'm not a
Comforts service dog expert I just know
that there's just different standards
and I've seen them work so I'm not
sure and that's what the commission's
for to figure all that
out thank you anyone
else all right seeing on thank you
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair so have we seen one of these
Comfort dogs
patch uh the Manchester
officer what's that the Manchester
officer that I don't see him here today
he's not here today but he has a dog by
the patch that we've actually had him
here in committee yep correct thank
you thank you thank you Sam
Hawkins
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee still a little bit of morning
left uh thank you for the opportunity to
testify today my name is Sam Hawkins I'm
the public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide I'm here today in on behalf of
Nomi New Hampshire to speak in support
of Senate Bill
367 mental health and suicide Ripple
throughout entire Community affecting
everyone but for our First Responders
this impact can be especially grave in
the course of their essential Work First
Responders are often directly exposed to
grief and pain not only that of the
community but also their own an
estimated 30% of First Responders
develop a behavioral health condition
such as depression and post-traumatic
stress disorder further while research
is limited emerging data suggests that
the risk of suicide and suicidal
ideation is elevated for First
Responders Nami New Hampshire applaud
the previous accomplishments of the
commission as well as the effort to
continue its work through this
legislation we're glad to be a named
member of the commission as well through
the continuing of this commission New
Hampshire has the opportunity to
continue to study this in issue
Implement changes to enable our full
understanding and invent and improve
methods to support some of our state's
bravest citizens our First Responders
provide a crucial service to our
communities and it's our responsibility
to support them so that they may
continue their important work and live
happy full lives for these reasons Nam
New Hampshire urges the committee to
recommend OTP for this Bill thank you
questions Simon thank you madam chair um
having been a part of the commission you
said you were part of the commission our
organization I'm not the representative
um is Nami aware of any successes like
are we seeing a decrease in suicidality
as we're implementing any specific
protocols that are coming out of the
commission or just in general are youw
thank you for the your question the
commission's started its work long
before I joined the organization i'
would be happy to go back to our
executive director who has sat on the
commission and get an answer to that
question for that would be great if you
wouldn't mind emailing us that' be
fantastic thank
you else thank you very much thank you
very
much Russell
Cony
uh good morning to everyone here on this
honorable uh committee my name is
Russell K I currently the mental health
and wellness coordinator for the
Department of Safety Division of State
Police and I am also a past president of
the board of directors for Nomi New
Hampshire I'm a p a past chair of the
suicide prevention Council for the state
and uh I have been employed as a first
responder law enforcement officer for
almost 39 years um I just wanted to come
in because I've been the department of
safety representative to this commission
since its Inception and just to let
everybody know that apart from the other
things that were brought up and all
great points and appreciate Nami and
certainly uh representative PR and all
the work that Senator burnel has done
but how much uh it has become a focal
point for First Responders and helping
themselves and having the ability to see
things that we really weren't keeping
track of when I started there was there
was next to no mental health or any
training at all that would leave you to
understand postt Trum traumatic or acute
stress or all the all the damaging
effects of the job um and unfortunately
we've lost um you know First Responders
to suicides that I have personally known
we have had people enter into
retirements that are not peaceful and
even though they may have earned one
we've had a lot of U careers cut short
and you know uh uh numerous marriages
and relationships dissolved uh because
of some of the stresses of the job so
this commission has brought together uh
the right people and the right people
are at the table it is a very well
attended commission uh every meeting um
and it gives us the ability to look at
what are really the important issues
because the people that are sitting at
the table have experienced them
themselves so um it has been a
tremendous value to those people that
are actually doing the work and I
oversee all the PE peer Serv services
for state police and uh for the
Department of Safety and that um we are
helping people get through uh incidents
where they have acute and post-traumatic
stress and keep them from entering a
phase where it becomes so debilitating
that they can't come to work or that
they have uh you know are considering
suicidal ideations as an option and I
know there's been a couple of questions
but uh suicide with First Responders is
something that's very hard to track and
it's something we talk about a lot and I
could tell you anecdotally I responded
to First Responders in crisis that were
having suicidal ideations and got them
to a place where they were cared for and
got them to professionals and I know we
saved lives
unfortunately um the statistics are
shocking uh when it comes to uh First
Responders suicides and I'm talking
First Responders as a whole firefighters
and police dispatchers and police
officers and and EMTs had the whole
group group as a whole so it's something
that has to be worked on and frankly
unless we have commissions like this
literally with their foot on the gas all
the time assuring that we're looking at
this and hearing from the right people
we have some tremendous speakers that
come to these meetings um uh that it's
it's it's a tough one to nail down and
you have direct questions and they're
very hard to answer because
realistically there's been very little
um that has been done to focus and this
particular Commission in this group is
one that is not repeated very often in
the country um so I think it's it's of
tremendous value it it it reminds me of
why I've been so proud to be a
professional in New Hampshire and that
we are usually out in front of a lot of
important issues so I just uh wanted to
just add just a couple of comments on
the value of it and the value of it to
First Responders not only like me uh
that came on when I did but all the new
people entering the profession and if
you came into the first responder
profession within the last 10 years uh
when we really got things off the ground
you would know it no different there
will always be help for you there will
always be professionals there will
always be people that are willing to get
you through a very rough spot in your
career and that is going to make a huge
difference and I don't know how you know
hopefully we can track it by all these
great young professionals that enter the
first responder profession and that go
into retirement and can tell you Hey
listen it was it wasn't easy but there
was people there to help me through it
so I thank you for the time and uh and
your and your your
ear thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you ma'am does anyone
else wish wish to testify on Senate Bill
367 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing we resume at 1
pm
for
e
all right it being one
o'clock we have somebody
here
yes exactly for the committee's
reference there are now copies of the
non- gerain amendment to Senate Bill 318
over on the table if you want one in
hard copy
Mr uh Tetro Tetro Tetro okay thank
you uh good afternoon uh Madam chair and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Phil Tetro and I am
Senator vard's legislative Aid uh I'm
here to introduce sp479 on behalf of
Senator richardi today uh Senator
richardi wishes she could be here today
to introduce this important legislation
however she was already committed to an
event in her District uh in 2018 senator
shardi was the driving force behind
getting a Proclamation signed by
Governor sonunu recognizing children's
environmental health day uh sp479 will
officially establish the second Thursday
in October as children's environmental
health day uh which the governor will
recognized annually with a proclamation
uh this will help promote awareness and
educate Granite Staters about the
importance of Clean Air clean water safe
food and safe consumer products uh thank
you for allowing me the opportunity to
speak today and and if you have any
questions I'm happy to bring them to
Senator shardi so she can get back to
you with an answer thank
you very good are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony are you any
relative all
right is there anyone else wishes to
testify on Senate Bill 479 I guess not
since there's nobody else we'll close
the
hearing well well let's trry somebody
else um does someone have a motion on
this are we going to go into executive
session we'll go into executive session
yes representative Bailey moved itl is
there second I'll
second do you wish to speak to your
motion no representative gr thank you
Madame chair
um it has been the policy of this
committee not to adopt special
days not because we don't care about
them but because there is no vehicle
that really um allows the promotion or
expansion of the information that is
expected as a result of this special day
and until we have that I don't we have
decided
to um itl these bills in
committee any represent go thank you
madam chair I will say we have
numerous days in the statute that a lot
of people don't even know are are there
due to the um inactivity of these
organizations once they petition this
committee to get them put into statute
um we just heard from the individual
that uh the senator had the governor do
a proclamation which I think is very
appropriate
to yearly go to the governor and justify
why the proclamation should be made
versus just putting it in statute and
letting it be buried there um so I think
we have a uh heard from this gentleman
that it was done before and I think
continuing to do that will bring these
groups out to petition the governor
thank you all
right anyone else I'd like to say I
agree with representative
goalie if there's no one else then the
motion is inexpedient to legislate and
the clerk can call the
role representative Bailey
yes representative
Dolan representa
Gard yes clz representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes yes
representative Smith yes represent
manager
py yes and the chair yes 15 y z n all
right the motion passes 15 to zero any
objections to
consent seeing none we'll put it on
consent representative Bailey at your
earliest convenience no later than
Monday tomorrow will be
good what was the name of that Committee
in in uh during the French
Revolution
that
people committee
what
yes we do our
part all right U I have another motion
Madam chair if you I had a motion I
didn't have another one before um I move
a to pass on Senate Bill 376
367 second okay that's by
representative Gro I second by
representative goalie I
believe okay you to speak to your motion
yes so I I did some research on the
committee and found that they IND do
they indeed um meet often they have uh a
well um staffed committee commission I'm
sorry of the members that are um that
are important to this Mission and they
have issued final reports reports as
requested and since they've done all the
work that is respected of a commission I
would hope that the committee would
agree to reinstate
them
go thank you madam chair
and when a senator comes to this
committee who is heading up a commission
and asking to continue the work of the
commission and the work they're doing um
I applaud her for the work she's doing
um and to keep this commission going
um it's dear and near to me and
important to me to watch the work this
commission does um as everyone knows I'm
a retired captain manchest of fire and
for the last day of my work and my
career was going to the funeral of one
of my
working one of the men that worked at my
station that had committed suicide
so this is near and dear to my heart and
I hope we can support this thank you
anyone
else pres
Gard yeah I'd like to comment that I'm
very optimistic about this Commission
because there is not one person
appointed by the governor and
counsel every everybody is appointed by
an organization that cares about the
results so they will get people
appointed quickly and get rolling fast
so
I'm more impressed than I am with most
commissions anyone else representative
Schmid thank you madam chair and I share
the sentiments that my colleagues have
expressed already this this is a a real
issue and this is there's also something
that can be done about it and these
these Comfort dogs and so forth but the
recognition of the stress that these
people are
under uh dealing with trauma that that
most of us never experiened and never
even hear about and they're dealing with
it on a daily basis so I'm totally in
support of this Bill thank you anyone
else okay um the motion is ought to pass
by representative gr and the clerk can
call the
role represent Lakers yes representative
Bailey yes representative Dolan
representative geard clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Smith yes representative
man py yes and the chair yes 16
a0
okay any
objections all right we'll put that one
on consent
also
and still that a few
minutes so do we want to talk about uh
[Music]
no can we speak about 437 if we can talk
about it without Noti it because it was
it's we heard it today therefore we can
talk we don't have to vote on it but uh
we can talk
about well if we can if we can talk
about it um
representative Maguire representative um
oh my gosh it's Patrick and I talked
about this because I think essentially
what the bill is trying to do is trying
to um say to municipalities that if they
do not send their their amendments to
the bill R you their fire amendments or
their oh my God amendments the state
fire code or the state building codes to
the appropriate person either the State
Fire marcial or the building review the
building code review board then those
amendments won't will not be enforced
until they've been
submitted
appropriately and I
guess we'd like to I like to we both
would like a sentence that says
municipalities who submit local
amendments in compliance with this
statute
um have amendments that are fully
enforcable and I don't know whether or
not I don't know how we're going to
enforce that who's going to be
responsible for not enforcing that's the
part that I can't okay representative
laus yeah so I think that according to
this they not only have to submit it but
they have to be confirmed confirmed what
he said confirmation is just making sure
that they passed it through a legal
process it doesn't conflict with the
statute violate the statute which are
things like it can't be less stringent
in the building code it can't try and
replace a whole chunk and all that and
then it's
automatic um so is the concern that you
want them to be able to enforce it
before that confirmation has occurred
and if so is the concern the building
code review board isn't is going to sit
on it or no what I'm saying is how is it
that well municipalities who don't abide
by
this right yeah to begin with why would
they not enforce see this is the thing
who's going to make sure that those
building that those amendments are not
being enforced so I I I mean somebody I
don't know somebody could complain so I
mean you could sue them and if they're
not if they're trying to enforce
amendments which are not but who's going
to sue who who's going to Su you town
the Builder or somebody who's building
that they're being told they can't do by
the okay the okay the unapproved
ordinance no okay would be able to soo
the town and I don't know if anybody
could just go to the AG and report them
if they do anything I don't know how
that works the AG I don't think would be
the right place to take a complaint
against a town it would be um super
Court yeah the town might take
a take
a somebody applying for an illicit
building permit to the AG but not not
the other way around okay I was and then
that would be a defense if they're
trying to enforce something they not
have they don't have the legal right to
do and yeah yeah I mean the the trouble
is that in many cases if the building
inspector decides he wants it done this
way even without a formal
ordinance he can make life very
miserable for anybody involved I've
talked to people who've been doing work
in some towns where that's what what
goes on they make up their own rules and
and if you don't go along with it life's
going to be difficult so goalie thank
you m
chair I like what this is doing I just
wish we
could put some teeth to it like we've
done with the reporting requirements for
the retirement system and if you don't
do it there's a penalty associated with
it because I don't think it's fair to
those Builders to have to now pick up
court costs and attorney fees because
hey town is going gone Rogue and wanting
to enforce their own rules however they
feel fit and that's just an issue I have
I mean I have no problem passing this
without it but I think there should be
some teeth to it I I agree with you
completely representative
Gart I'm wondering though if it's
possible to to quantify those costs so
if you if you have a job lined up you
have different subcontracts coming in at
different times if the building
inspector wants to make up some fugazi
elect you know electrical requirements
and now you miss your other
subcontractors D it's going to be hard
to say how much money you've really lost
and I think it would also set up maybe
potential for false lawsuits and I don't
know I just that might get kind of messy
just thinking off
hand the town should be penalized for
not putting on to submitting to the
building code review board or the Fire
Control Board their amendments showing
so that they're posted online what they
are my
my point being is if the building
inspector just went off the reservation
by himself it wasn't something do you
know what I mean he's just making stuff
up it happens I'm just saying so we've
heard representative lus yeah I'm just
wondering on that one um so who who
would how would that be enforced who
would be responsible if you're not if
it's not going to be a civil suit by a a
builder or something then you know could
be reported to some somebody who in the
government who then does something or
how how do you envision that working
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair well if if
we have these concerns I think we ought
to have a subcommittee but the but the
bottom line is the building code review
board uh and um Carol you you you know
you've been dealing with this issue for
almost as long as I have uh and that the
building code review board is a very
experienced uh in institution that
headed by a real sharp guy Phil Sherman
has been on top of the situation for
about four or five years now as the
chair uh and um and the and and Gary
Abbott has
been 20 years I've been here and he's
been coming in with all with regard to
all these issues but there is there was
some question about some language you
remember that was a little bit stickier
they weren't sure and I think we ought
to take a look at that and and see it
but it's w with with this group I think
you're and you have Bill McKenna has
been here for all the time I've been on
Edna as well uh and the Builders
Association and build building
officials uh City oversight officials
they're all working together uh and
monitoring this and so forth and I think
they have a a pretty good enforcement
procedure worked out but we ought to
look at that the language and see if we
can't perfect it as long as we have some
questions let's ask
him I mean I'm I'm I'm ready to vote on
yes on the bill but but why not fix it
if it's got some
issues thank you madam chair so there's
there's two we're talking about two
different enforcement pieces one is the
person to enforce against the town for
for making them follow a code that
wasn't approved and the other one is can
the state somehow enforce against the
towns that don't follow this law that's
what you're saying right how do we track
whether the towns do follow this or not
that's a always a challenge put notice
as a followup I would say on we know how
they if they do follow the procedure we
know about it because they've submitted
their amend
if however a
municipality doesn't have any amendments
you don't know if it's because they
haven't bothered to tell us or because
they don't want to make any
amendments repres blackis right I mean
maybe um if there's some place whether
it's building code review board or
somebody else where someone who is aware
that you know they've created these uh
rules without going through the
process um you know maybe something
could be done for whether it's building
cone review board or someone else to
deal with it but I think I mean either
it's going to be reported by somebody
who becomes aware of it or the case
where somebody objects to what they're
doing and and either they're being sued
or they sue the town or you'd have to
have you know somebody do some kind of
Investigation of all the ordinances of
all the municipalities which I don't see
happening so but if there's a way for
somebody who notices as a problem to
report it and then an investigation be
done then maybe that could
work remember two two things number one
the fire marshal said um that
that you got all these professional
firefighters in the bigger towns or
cities okay and you got volunteer
firefighters and they know but he
mentioned the fact that they had uh in
one of the towns I think that they were
putting it through the
zoning zba right and it was not a legal
thing at all there was no legally
adopted ordinance in the town they were
letting the zba do it completely
inappropriate and not
legal and so forth but they're getting a
handle on all this and it's much more
effective than it used to be in my
opinion but let's ask the questions that
we
have Peter on your
subcomittee okay I think there are
enough questions that we should schedule
a sub committee um particularly since I
asked about the legal question we
haven't got a response back yet uh yes
represent goie thank you madam chair and
I guess I apologize for bringing up and
throwing the bomb into the works but um
it it was just a thought obviously I
don't think we have the time to work on
something of that aspect this year but I
just think if we're going to do
something requiring cities and towns to
do it there ought to be some sort of
penalty like reporting in the retirement
system at a later date to make sure it's
done appropriately and on time
MH okay representative Simon I think
your question your comment uh yes just
real briefly if I remember correctly um
the legality issue was kind of circling
around whether or not we could
retroactively um take away the
enforcement ability of the
municipalities to enforce the code that
they had put in the interim but if I
understood Mr Sherman correctly that's
going to be a moot point because as soon
as this bill is passed we'll be updating
to the 2021 codes in the 2018 codes
different bill this is a different Bill
oh yes oh I'm sorry I came into the room
my my apologies yes I think we might
want to put in an exp explicit comment
that you know amendments that apply to
previous versions of the code are hereby
repealed
because uh
you might okay and this is going to
representative Simon subcommittee with
representative Schmid which one we 437
yes um
this you'll get to have fun with that
thank
okay did
that got such a beautiful smile thank
you
pet okay so I think that's all the bills
we have before
us so out of we have five minutes before
our next hearing
this should was
the
e
all right welcome
back it being 1:30 I'm opening the
public hearing on set up Bill 4:30 and I
call Senator
bsel uh thank you for uh entertaining um
my Senate Bill 430 my name for the
record my name is Regina berzel uh state
senator for Derry Hamstead and Windham
and I am the prime sponsor of Senate
Bill 430 and I find myself here again
and I and I did thank you for passing my
um the um commission thank you very much
um this W this bill um was a request
from the EV emergency response Round
Table um it's been a discussion I know
it's been a discussion at the New
Hampshire Transportation Council when I
was member and chair of
Transportation um also I went to a
couple of the EV uh Round Table meetings
and there is a lot of concern from our
First Responders on how to handle EV
fires and lithium
batteries so uh and we just heard a bill
a house bill actually in the in Senate
energy which I'm a member of as well um
on um correct disposal of lithium
batteries so this mission is required is
required to study the occurrence of
electric vehicles lithium ion battery
and E Mobility device fire department
responses in New Hampshire and I might
add I just saw on the news today um
there was a
spontaneous ebike that um blew up and
caught on fire in London and I guess
there's been a few in the US as well so
that's something to be aware of um it's
also going to study the impacts of
Public Safety and it's a council it's
not a commission
um the impacts of Public Safety response
and personal protective equipment the
impacts to the built environment one of
the things that came up in the New
Hampshire Transportation Council when um
Victoria Sheen was still our
um uh Commissioner of
Transportation the discussion was around
the EV fires and how hot they burned and
her concern came out that okay so what
happens if one of these cars catches on
fire in the middle of the White
Mountains we don't have 4,000 was it
four
4,000
gallons 4,000 gallons or more to put
this fire out the the comment was well
then you have to let it burn out well at
4,000 and whatever however many
thousands of degrees it is that means
the road is going to melt um wherever
that EV is so when we say built
environment we um we talk we we're
talking about the roads we're also
talking about garages that are attached
to buildings that have EV Chargers um so
that's when when we say built
environments that's what we're talking
about um the impacts to the environment
to include air water ground pollution
impacts to the as I said the State
Transportation Systems which I just um
explained the cost in administration of
first responder training and impacts to
building and fire codes because that
that is one thing that I'm um we had a
cond I'm in a condo and their tow houses
and are they're four units each with a
um Garage in between each unit and I
brought it up at our last meeting that
we need to start putting some rules in
our condos about it because if if
someone comes in with and puts a car
charger in there that's going to impact
us if anything happen happens to it um
you can guarantee that all four of those
units are going to go up if one of those
because they burn at a pretty high rate
and pretty fast so um this this uh
council is going to be studying those
things and I'm sure that's why the Fire
Marshall is
here so I will entertain any
questions okay thank you I'd like to
commend you for
selecting um your council members that
the governor and Council don't have to
be involved that that tends to be a
delaying Factor you're
welcome anyone other questions seeing
none thank you not
an thank you okay Sean
toi good afternoon Sean Tumi State Fire
Marshall um
so I think Senator Bell did a great job
introducing the bill um I can tell you
that the uh our office um started some
sort of Round Table discussions if you
will this summer um and trying to bring
stakeholders together uh from the
different disciplines just to talk about
the hazards uh and any concerns around
electric vehicle fires and lithium ion
battery fires and trying to figure out
how to educate um the the fire service
and First Responders we include law
enforcement as well on this because
they'll be responding to some of these
incidents um and and trying to figure
out Outreach to the consumers as well um
we're not looking to block any of these
devices they're here we have them I have
two phones on me they both have
batteries in them um you know but I
think the education and being thoughtful
about uh how to handle them and and
making any necessary changes to codes
and and practice make sense so uh
Senator Birdsell was kind enough to work
with us to um sponsor this bill really
to bring together we had asked initially
was a commission change to council but
just sort of formalize the group that we
developed the suar hopefully to get the
bulk of the stakeholders that would be
involved and um bring forth the report
preliminary report in November of this
year and a final report following
November to um recommend any changes uh
if necessary to around the areas of
electric vehicle fires and lithium
battery fires um as far as electric
vehicle fires we have 3 or 400 car fires
in the state a year we think there's
only been uh two or three electric
vehicle Fires at this point um so the
occurrence isn't huge uh but when they
do occur they typically are much more uh
intensive as far as resourc driven for
uh the Water Supply uh just to put them
out um the the e-mobility type devices
are susceptible to Thermal thermal
Runway if they're typically if they're
damaged mismatch with devices for
charging and things like that and we're
you know especially concerned about
educating consumers about using listed
devices um charging with appropriate
equipment and you know following
manufacturers and recommendations when
they're in use uh so we've been pushing
a lot of that information messaging and
stuff through our social media outlets
and and such but um if they do have a
fire you know as as a center di mention
like in a condo situation um especially
more like an apartment buildings we want
uh you know put store them store them in
the appropriate places don't put them in
the means of egress and things like that
there was a a fire in um uh term at UNH
earlier this year it was a makeshift uh
ebike uh that had a fire in one of the
dorms fortunately there was no uh
injuries or um anything but you know
that those are things we need to think
about so um I guess our ask for you is
just to help formalize that group and
then for us to you know for us to bring
back our our task be bring back any
recommendations there's a lot of
national National interest at this point
on the code side and the fire service
side studying this uh Underwriters Labs
or UL has got a big has funded a big
study through the fire service research
institute NFPA who does the fire codes
is they through their Research
Foundation is devoted a bunch of stuff
and then ICC who does our building codes
it's got an ad hoc committee uh working
to look at the building code so we're
you know we're looking to them and their
expertise as well to guide us a little
bit on some of this so happy to try to
answer any questions thank you repres
and then Dolan Andi thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question I
have two uh questions one you did
mention about the phones and the
batteries are here and we just heard the
laptop catching fire in next state over
so are we going you know we can't ban
everything so how do we deal with that
um batteries are here to stay and the
Technologies are
changing my second part to it is how are
other states that have EV infrastructure
and EV vehicles are dealing with that as
the technology
changes and uh how is New Hampshire
keeping up with
that I think we're behind a little bit
on some of the other the advancement of
EV technology in our state I I don't
have the numbers off the top of my head
right now the number of EVS that we have
but compared to other states I know
we're we're behind a bit right um our
Curren of fires are much less but I
think that um they are here to stay I
think the good news is there's a lot of
work going on science to try to change
the batteries and the stability of the
batteries which will help um but I think
we I think my focus is really on the
education consumer education and making
you know making sure that uh we have
that information that's out there but um
we want we want to watch the numbers we
don't want to overreact to you
there one
followup thank you so how will this
impact are tourism the tra uh tourists
from outside of the state they're using
more and more
EV how will this Council impact tourism
not Council if we don't have the
infrastructure if we don't have the
charging station if you don't encourage
that um representative maner py that's
totally beyond the scope of this this
this
council do you have a question that's
related to The
Bill yes so the council is looking at
how to
address the EV and the fire and what it
takes so how that impacts if you don't
look at it and find a solution we may
not have EVS in our state but how will
it affect the Travelers that come to our
state if you don't have well I suspect
that if the uh this commission finds
that EV Chargers are a major fire hazard
which I don't think they're going to
find but if they do then we would not
build anymore we would not allow anyone
to build anymore and we would warn
people not to bring your EVS into New
Hampshire I mean that would be
the worst case or the best case
depending on how you thought about it
but that would be one
extreme
correct I think never
mind yeah I don't know I'm not sure how
to quite answer I think that's outside
the scope of what we were looking at but
okay representative dlan had a question
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question this so this question
is um
might the answer might be that's why
they we're going to do the study and
that the question is uh with lithium
iron
batteries
U is there any uh consideration of not
allowing those EVS to to be parked in
parking garages where a fire could start
and not be able to be put out or is that
something that you're going to be
studying with this bill uh I think the
the impacts to building of fire codes is
what we were looking at so that would be
probably uh connected to that there's
there are studies nationally that are
going on that looking at the parking
garages parking garage fires in general
right now because the data what we've
learned the the the design fires and
such for parking garages and car fires
is based on car fires from the 70s and
80s and now that we've introduced
Plastics into all of our cars that's a
very different fire than what the
designs are anyway so um you know I
think that the car fires in parking
garages in general is being studied not
only because of EVS so um all of that
data will be I would Envision being
incorporated as part of this um
Council representative
sh thank you madam chair well I mean
we're all aware that we're most of us
are driving around in vehicles that are
potential explosive bombs right we got
20 gallons or however many gallons you
got in your tank you know that uh
carfire is not a nice thing no matter
what the heck you're powering it with uh
but the bottom line is uh that we have
all these devices they're here to stay
maybe the batteries will be completely
redesigned but the the the question I
have is there's no fiscal
note uh but it's go I you're going to
have to do some research I presume that
you're I didn't look to see are you the
head of it or I I learned I am the head
of it I'm going to be the chair of this
I I think that happened in the amendment
but that's fine the design yeah I'm good
with that uh so this this is all good
but I'm just kind of a secondary
question is I mean we have UNH over
there with
chemists uh scientists uh physicists and
so forth and so on
uh uh are we looking at whether we have
some homegrown research so that we're
not completely dependent on what they're
doing down in Massachusetts or
California or wherever where they've got
many times our
population I I believe we have a pretty
good representation in the group that we
identified auto dealers the tow
associations the fire chiefs Dees dot
like I mean we have I think we have a
good mix and then you know it does talk
about being able to bring in others so I
think we have I think between what we
have and tapping into a few friends
around we I think we'll be in pretty
good shape it's my guess thank you thank
you B blackis yeah this is uh I think a
question for the chair whoever can
answer it what what's the uh sort of
technical def difference between a
council and a commission and a committee
committee commission I think I I know
what a committee is that's legislators
what's the difference do you know the
difference between a council and a
commission I don't so my understand we
came at it with a commission which would
have had um a couple of reps on it and
and Senator on it and then what we
learned from recent changes is that the
the commissions it has to be made up of
more members of the general court than
there are people on the committee y I
remember that um and this as council is
new I don't know as amended it has no
members of the legislature yes yes thank
you for you talk to us and explain what
we'll read your uh reports and uh take
action if necessary yeah okay
representative Shu and then Brown
thank you madam chair thank you Fire
Marshall um and I'm not sure if this is
too appropriate but I'm just curious if
you know if you can tell us do these
fires start because of the lithium
battery because of the charger the
connection between the two or is it like
all of the
above typically it's some sort of
failure mechanism um in the cars it's
usually typically some sort of damage or
some
impurity and type thing in the batter is
seems to be what the thing is and then
it causes thermal Runway which causes
the the fire event so um I don't the
charger itself doesn't seem to be the
culprit most of the times but it can
happen right um so um it's usually a
damage or an impurity type thing is what
most of them seem to be coming at this
point but we're still learning a lot
right and that's I think we'll continue
to learn a bit for a
while Brown you had a question uh yes
thank you madam chair uh thanks for
taking my question I think it doesn't
say this specifically but should this
apply to um solar systems and the
batteries and houses and you could
probably just go there anyway but it
doesn't say that
specifically
um we could probably lump that in on
lithium biome batteries and impacts on
the building
codes um without too much of a stretch I
would
say
follow Madam chair thank you I know uh
my neighbors have a battery system that
will last them for seven days to run
everything in their
house and um but so I'm assuming that
those could be a pretty good source of
uh some heat if they were a fire in the
home so enough said thank
you good
point any anyone else yes ah repr of
Gard than matter CH just quick question
for you as as far as because I've seen
some video online of electric cars
hitting each other and the explosions
it's pretty intense the the amount you
said there's only three I believe
electric car accidents or vehicle
collisions or fires I'm sorry yeah is
that due maybe you don't know I'm just
curious is that due to the technology on
these cars that stops collisions like
the self-driving aspect or is that just
chance or is it just you don't know the
two of them are involved in accidents um
and I'm not sure quite about the third
um is what happened but beyond that the
New Hampshire ones I don't know
okay I mean I as I say I mean the when
you look at some of the data like even
on Tesla and stuff when you really drill
into it some of them are crashing into
things right so cars when they crash
into things Catch Fire unfortunately we
had the the death yesterday in in um in
B right unfor the motorcycle there was a
fire involved in that right I we it
seems like every year we have someone
that crashes a car into a tree or or the
um the toll boost or something like that
and it catches fire so uh I think that
that unfortunately that current those
accidents do happen Okay thank you yeah
okay
represent thank you um thank you chair
um Mr Fire Marshall is
the the scope of the of the study do you
feel that there's enough time within a
year to do all these things I hope so
that I mean it's a pretty hefty
lift I think we'll get some preliminary
information out and then I think that's
why it gives us another year to get us
hopefully get some more information is
is my hope um you know will we solve it
all probably not but I think we'll we'll
have a better sense um okay you we we'll
have a better sense within that time
representative laus yep there's uh two
deadlines one do at the end of this year
and one do at the end of next year so
yeah okay anyone
else all right thank you very much thank
you Rebecca
oler good afternoon Rebecca erer
Department of Environmental Services I'm
in the air Resources Division uh the
department is very supportive of this
bill we look forward to taking the
opportunity to get more data um I I was
hoping that I could get a response to to
a text to tell you exactly how many
electric vehicles we have register in
the state but my best guess is going to
be in the 1800 to
2000 um range right now but it's
certainly growing we we're seeing the
the rate of EV adoption grow um at an
accelerating rate I I myself own an EV
so um you know obviously from an air
quality standpoint we are excited about
the Advent of electric vehicles I mean
even factoring in all of the manufact
cure of all of the components of the
vehicle it's still a far less polluting
vehicle option than than an internal
combustion engine but from the other
side of my agency from the Water
Division from the waste division we're
also concerned about the disposal of
batteries about the potential for for
contamination from fires uh and so the
makeup of this commission seems to bring
bring all of the right players to the
table and we look very we we look
forward to being part of this
conversation and and working to bring as
much information to the table as we can
thank you thank any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony does anyone else wish to
testify on Senate Bill
430 seeing none I will close the
hearing okay we'll go into executive
session does someone have a
motion I'll move out to pass Madam
chair
okay representative Schmidt is
maintaining his position as the official
second representative Simon do you to
speak to your motion thank you madam
chair it seems like all the interested
parties are actually interested in
having this conversation um be good to
gather the information that they're
looking into I think it' be useful and
uh so I guess for those reasons uh I
would move out to pass I'd also just
like to add that if we have found a way
to do these things without any
legislators involved we're probably
going to see more councils in the future
and fewer committee and commissions
that's that's my guess so I would so we
might as well give one a try and see how
it goes all right representative Schmidt
do you wish to speak to your second I do
M yes um I mean this is a proverbial
no-brainer we we've got something that's
coming at us like a car at 80 mil an
hour uh that has all kinds of unknown
aspects in terms of having a personal
experience with it as I said earlier
we're most of us are driving around with
with things that have got a highly
flammable highly explosive thing uh that
and
and that's
going 60 or 70 M hour down the road with
other vehicles coming in other direction
so uh we we have gas furnaces gas water
heaters uh gas stoves and so forth in
our houses uh and we've learned to live
and sometimes die by the all these
things so this is a no-brainer to have
this Council to look into this and
develop more expertise to advise us
wisely in terms of how we're going to
deal with this as it gets more and more
and more uh
ubiquitous representative uh Gart and
then Dolan well I'm almost done and that
is we're all we're also we're also
carrying little heaters in our pockets
right you ever touch it and go like wow
this is hotter than I thought you know
so forth and it's got an lithium ion
battery in it ever see how they're
created they're all wound up and so
forth and so forth so we need to learn
more about this except by personal
experience thank you we'll try not to
let anybody burn burn up from their
phones representative
Gart thank you madam chair I'm
questioning so we're going to look at
not we they we'll look at the effects on
the environment well
I'm concerned that we're not looking at
the full effects as in how the lithium
is mined I think that's kind of a larger
equation I mean that is an effect on the
environment and some uh local
geopolitical aspects so just saying
something I was thinking about okay
represent
Dolan thank you madam chair uh my
question is more administrative in that
uh we're rounding up a a fairly large
population of state employees to do this
this work um and probably some people
that are on the higher end of the pay
scale of state
employees uh yet we have no fiscal node
do we do we think that we're going to be
able to accomplish this for for no
cost uh the thing is that all those high
level state employees such as the fire
marshal are considered to be
unclassified they do not have to punch a
time clock
and if they H we our expectation is
usually that they will work extra hours
if necessary to make this
happen thank you I would just point out
a lot of them have or design
also yes yes or they have staff that are
sitting around twiddling their thumbs
not answering the phones that they can
go to these
meetings
um representative Brown and then maner
buy
uh thank you madam chair a couple of
comments I know I read this at home and
I made a note under the environment to
representative gard's comment I said why
is this under 154 so uh RSA 154 is fire
hazards so if it if it as it's under 154
and fire hazards then it shouldn't be
jumping over to other topics that that I
think that you and I were I was
concerned at home for the same question
you had okay and appreciate that
represent man py
thank you madam chair I I'm trying to
control my comment all I'll say is
knowledge is power ignorance is not
Bliss that's all thank
you yes represent Brown sorry madam
chair just as a followup I I think this
is a good idea because a number of times
this year we've had this conversation
about how many have these fires have
there been and where have they been and
fire parking garages so I think it's a a
wonderful idea yes it will help us to
deal with our study our interim study of
the bill to ban EVS because we can refer
to this
Council anyone
else all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass by representative Simon
and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Dolan
representative gearhard yes CLK vote Yes
representative voyd yes representative
Brown yes representative gr yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitz Patrick yes
representative Smith yes representative
manuti yes and the chair yes 17 yay zero
nay all right the motion passes 17 to
zero any objections to
consent seeing none we'll put this on
consent and we have two minutes before
the next
hearing we are so fortunate that way
yes
it's a good
anything that's a good thing to put in
that's a good reason
to and it doesn't involve us so it's
like a win all the way
around it yes all read their
reports think was on one of take my with
go that's
I've
e
thank you all welcome back I'm opening
the public hearing on Senate Bill 210
and I call the prime sponsor Senator
Carson good afternoon Madam chair and
good afternoon again to the members of
the House Edna committee for the record
my name is Sharon Carson and I have the
pleasure of representing uh Senate
District 14 comprising the towns of
Auburn londonerry and Hudson and I have
for for your consideration this
afternoon Senate Bill 210 which seeks to
require all software contracts entered
into by a state agency not to limit the
agency's ability to run and install
software on the infrastructure of the
agency's choosing and approved by the
department of Information Technology
subject to certain statutory
Provisions
um this legislation would improve the
state's negotiation ability to prevent
restrictive software licensing terms and
business practices ensure greater choice
and more competition and protect against
surprise cost increases borne by the
state and taxpayers one area where this
legislation is particularly important it
is in cloud computing the evolution of
it systems has seen the rise in Cloud
Computing Services aimed at reducing
costs improving in efficiencies and
workflows and strengthening cyber
security
but States Across the Nation have been
discovering restrictions buried in
contracts on licensed portability and
additional charges for trying to use
software on anything other than the
other software providers own cloud
platform I believe it is important to
ensure our state agencies are
safeguarded against the potential
anti-competitive actions that tie the
hands of our it professionals and agency
personnel and place our systems data and
taxpayers at risk this bill is supported
by the Coalition for fair software
licensing for digital Innovation net
choice and computer and Communications
industry Association these diverse
interests represent National and
International Information Technology
companies that have worked jointly on a
set of fair licensing principles for
software that focus on op uh open
competition and fairness cyber security
portability to uh bring previously
purchased software to the cloud and
flexibility for the customer this
legislation is forward-looking and would
not impact current contractual
arrangements for software Hardware or
the cloud importantly the bill does not
mandate the state do anything
differently unless it chooses to do so
doit and its partner agencies maintain
full discretion and choice for it
procurement and
Contracting the bill aims only to
provide state agencies and doit more
leverage in the contract negotiations
for it which safeguards against rigid
expensive or predatory licensing
agreements that box New Hampshire into
costly less secure and less Innovative
products technology is advancing at an
amazing pace and our state should have
as much flexibility to make the choices
that best fit our needs in the future
the Senate passed uh this bipartisan
legislation by Voice Voice vote in
January it's worth noting that during
the Senate's consideration of Senate
Bill 210 there was no public testimony
offered in opposition to this bill
furthermore the commissioner of doit has
indicated that the bill will have zero
fiscal impact on the
state similar legislation has been acted
in Colorado Indiana Missouri Illinois
and Minnesota and is currently be
considered in Massachusetts New Jersey
and here it is also being introduced in
more than a doen dozen other states
because state governments like Private
Industry should not have Technology
Solutions forced upon them but rather be
afforded options that make technological
and Financial sense for their agencies
and their citizens um at this point
Madam chair I will conclude my testimony
and I will thank all of you for
listening and I ask you to support um
Senate Bill 210 thank you very much um
we have a lot of folks here today that
can answer questions better than I can
so um I appreciate your time and thank
you very much
okay commissioner
gulay
thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh Dennis goule uh the
commissioner for the Department of
Information Technology um here is a just
a quick courtesy visit today to uh first
of all um confirm what the senator just
communicated with respect to our um you
know feeling that uh this isn't going to
impact us negatively or positively in
the short term from a fin cial
perspective um and doit itself is not
taking a position on this bill um but I
wanted I did receive a lot of questions
on the Senate side uh that you know you
could interpret it as having an impact
and I want to make sure you you knew
that that we're not concerned with that
that respect and also I'm here to answer
any questions from our perspective if
need be thank you for being here are
there any
questions represent leus thanks could
you give us at least least one example
of some kind of a have there been
situations where there has been software
that the states wanted to purchase that
had restrictive requirements this bill
would prohibit at least have some feel
for sure what what we're seeing um is
some in some cases companies who have um
you know invested in vertical
integration so who have the you know the
ability to license software or subscri
software subscriptions and also own
infrastructure um do differentiate their
pricing based on whether you're hosting
in their environments or in one of their
competitor's environments or in your own
environment followup
followup um I'm seeing here
that it it can't be required to run you
they can't keep you from running on the
software you're choosing but it would
prevent uh I don't I'm not seeing where
prevent a difference in
pricing well you know I've I I would
agree with you sir um I you know I've
scratched my head about this language a
little bit and and wonder what the next
step is in in the you know I see this as
probably maybe a longer term
process that um that the um Coalition is
involved in I've asked them that
question explicitly what's the next
action and I have not received an answer
to that right thank you the Coalition is
the next next person to testify
representative Dolan thank you madam
chair
and the question that I have is uh one
that I know the federal government is is
wrestling with and that is are you does
this legislation or would this
legislation restrict yourself or the
Governor from the executive uh uh side
of the government restricting state
agencies from using C certain social
media platforms that I know like I said
the federal government is currently
wrestling with uh no I I don't see this
as relating to that although you know
there is an executive order out there
that
that um is um restricting the use of of
um certain Chinese Technologies on uh on
the state networks and we're enforcing
that but that's that's that's where I
was going thank you y any other
questions thank you very much Scott
Drexel
thank you m please turn your microphone
M my apologies thank you madam chair and
members of the committee for having me U
my name is Scott Drexel and I'm here on
behalf of the Coalition for fair
software licensing the Coalition was
launched in 2022 and it's comprised of
North American companies and trade
organizations representing AC
cross-section of key Industries
including Health Care Financial Services
manufacturing software and cloud and
cyber security providers the goals of
the Coalition are rooted in nine
principles of fair software licensing a
set of Industry practices aimed at
creating greater transparency Innovation
choice and Security in the cloud the
cloud offers significant opportunities
for software customers especially state
and local governments uh and other
public agencies to realize a wide swath
of public of benefits including cost
savings workflow efficiencies greater
flexibility for an evolving Workforce
and ultimately an increased capacity on
the part of State institutions to
provide critical services to their
constituents but in order to take
advantage of these possibilities that
the cloud has to offer public and
private entities should come together
around standards of fairness
transparency and choice for the customer
the legislation before you today takes
an important step toward that goal
particularly as it relates to the choice
of the customer in this case the state
very simply sb210 requires that
contracts for the purchase of software
by the state do not limit the ability of
state agencies to run that software
using the cloud provider of their choice
now why is this necessary prior to 2019
this was typical industry practice it
was called Bol bring your own license
once a customer purchased software
licenses the customer was allowed to
choose the hardware environment that
best met its business needs and that was
good it encouraged uh greater
interoperability vendor diversification
which is in the end good for cyber
security but in 2019 some Legacy
software providers began restricting out
of out of no particular technical
necessity where their software could be
run that new restriction was intended to
leverage the popularity of one product
line to sell additional goods and
services beyond the scope of any RFP
regardless of whether the customer
needed or wanted those additional
products uh it was intended to gain an
advantage in an increasingly competitive
cloud computing Market sp210 would
correct that Dynamic by ensuring that
the ultimate Choice belongs to the state
and Central it it would prevent the
vendor from dictating to the customer
again in this case the state um how the
customer can use the products that it's
already purchased at its core sp210 is a
technology procurement Good Housekeeping
bill it's narrowly tailored it applies
only to Future procurement contracts it
doesn't implicate any that are already
in effect uh it does not constrain the
state in its choice of software or of
cloud provider instead empowering state
agencies to select the software vendors
or Hardware environments that best meet
their business needs in fact it doesn't
require anything of the state at all uh
it incentivizes vendor
diversification um and again strengthens
cyber security it does not ask the state
to pick winners and losers instead it
Fosters healthy competition in the
public Cloud which lowers cost to
taxpayers it's a critical facet of free
enterprise right uh greater competition
in the marketplace lowers cost and it
Fosters Innovation uh prioritizes the
needs of the state over the preference
of the software vendor so um I I'll stop
there I just want to um sort of
reiterate this is um this is not a novel
bill it's it's already passed in
Colorado Missouri uh Illinois and most
recently Indiana um in in every case
overwhelmingly um because this is again
something that that really uh I think
treats the stewardship of of taxpayer
dollars um with a a high degree of
priority and um you know with with a
best practices for the industry in mind
um and again I I believe I've emailed it
to all of the committee members but
there's a joint letter in support of
this legislation from a number of of um
software industry groups including my my
group The Coalition for fair software
licensing net Choice um ccia the
computer Communications industry
Association and the alliance for digital
Innovation thank you very much thank you
are there any
questions pres Brown thank you madam
chair uh thanks for taking my question
thanks for being here is there so there
must be a a a benefit to software
Sellers from this am I am I reading
between the lines of what you're saying
to that a benefit to software sellers um
yes when you are a a um especially from
a standpoint of innovation right if you
have a a startup or a midsize company
that's able to sell their product um in
a way that that is that frees the state
from constraint around what additional
products and services it has to buy then
your product stands you know on its own
against the other product that that the
big guy offering so it is it is a net
benefit to software providers in the
sense that you you're you're not having
sort of um anti-competitive behavior on
the part of large companies that are
preventing smaller and midsize
innovators in the marketplace from from
offering a product that could benefit
the the the state or or the
customer thank you thank you sir any
other
questions excellent job thank you very
much thank you madam chair is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
Senate Bill
210 okay so I'll close the public
hearing okay
M okay we'll go into executive session
does someone have a motion sure I'll
make the motion of ought to pass on
Senate Bill
210 is there a second uh second
okay represent blackis y
um I mean this doesn't put any
restrictions on no I
guess it it gives the dit and other
state agencies the ability to run this
on whatever platform makes the best
sense from uh you know a financial or
other consideration point of view which
I think is positive and um it also
prevents a possible situation where
you've got you want software from a
number of different vendors they require
their software to run on different
platforms so now you got to deal with
these different platforms if you want
their software which is which
complicates uh the job and probably
makes it more expensive so I think in
general it's a good idea representative
Brown um I thank you madam chair I I
would just mention that that while I was
a Dees we spent a very large sum of of
of money on uh of Homeland Security gram
money on a an air modeling software that
would help the track toxics released in
the air in an emergency
situation and it came down to the fact
that um we had one device it could be
used on and when that person left and
moved we were not allowed to move it or
put it on another device or do anything
with it and it became defunct in about
10 months so I'm so sorry to hear
that anyone
else all right in that case the motion
is ought to pass by representative
leus and the clerking all the RO
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative
Dolan clerk votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht
yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Smith yes represent man
py yes in the chair yes 16 y zero nay
all right motion passes any objection to
consent all right we'll put that one on
consent and our next hearing starts at
2:30
e
all right good afternoon everyone I'm
opening the the public hearing on Senate
Bill 439 I call Senator
Bradley
good afternoon uh Madam chair members of
the committee for the record uh Jeb
Bradley from
wolfboro and here um as the sponsor of
Senate Bill 439 which obviously passed
the Senate and now is up for your
consideration um this bill is building
upon the executive action of the
governor um to say that executive
agencies cannot um participate in
anything that would be part of
boycotting
Israel uh the
governor created that executive order a
little over a year ago as I recall and I
felt that this legislation was important
in light of um what happened on October
7th and um the ongoing controversy so
the nuts and Bolt of the bill are
starting on page two where there's a new
section of RSA
211 um that starts with a definition of
what boycotting Israel
means um and then really the heart of
the matter is starting on line
203 and four that notwithstanding any
other provision ision of law no
executive branch agency May adopt any
investment policy that would have the
effect of requiring or inducing any
person to boycott Israel so
um with regard to executive branch
agencies they cannot invest in
companies um found to be boycotting
Israel they can't contract with
companies um this is the policy that the
governor adopted this would put it into
law and then as it goes further onto
page three um talks about what would
happen if there is a company boycotting
or an executive agency Israel so I think
you know to get back to the beginning of
the bill uh the purpose statement sort
of says the why um this is
important
um New Hampshire as I understand it does
a over aund million of exports as of
2021 um that means
substantial
job growth in this state
um the purpose statement goes on to say
that any boycott of entities or
individuals um amount to an ethnic
religious racial and or nationality
discrimination and it is consistent
um as outlined on line 17 and 18 that
it's the public policy of the United
States that's enshrined in several laws
that boycotts against Israel um are not
um are not to be tolerated
so that's the bill um as I said it
passed the Senate I believe
unanimously and I as I recall on a Voice
vote um sponsored by most of the
Senators and I hope that it will receive
a favorable reaction from you
folks thank you Senator we do have some
questions I'm Shu and then
lus thank you madam chair thank you
Senator uh for appearing before us um so
this is basically codifying the
governor's executive order and can you
tell us what's the difference between uh
codification and an executive order why
would this be better well I'm sorry
potentially an executive order could be
countermanded by a successive Governor
um if a successive Governor didn't issue
an executive order so this codifies it
it gives it the strength of
law representative lus thank you um I
see this is in uh 21i administrative
Services um um which includes
procurement um so would this affect or
not affect with the governor's executive
order does it affect uh the New
Hampshire retirement
system uh the New Hampshire retirement
system is
not an executive Ranch but I believe
that um the governor's executive order
covered the retirement system and so
this were my understanding is
also okay does followup followup
yeah I'm not seeing it included in here
so it doesn't seem like this legislation
would do that but I was wondering about
the uh the governor's executive order
but uh uh that is a good question I'm
sorry I don't have an answer all right
thank
you anyone
else thank you madam chair um Senator
Bradley the title is discrimination
boycots of Israel in state procurement
and Investments so if it would not
include the New Hampshire retirement
system what investments would the state
make other than that we'll let him
answer sorry so if I I guess what I
would suggest is let me do a little
research and
determine whether the retirement system
is included in this or not my thought
was it was but you might be right
representative
leakas
repr thank you madam chair thank you uh
Senator Bradley for appearing taking my
question um this legislation is
obviously
targeted uh to prohibit uh boycotts of
Israel uh other what other
countries are there currently uh issues
with procurement other than Israel uh I
mean what what what countries are we
currently discriminating against other
than
Israel I don't know if there are
any but
I I'm just I'm not certain of that
either thank
you representative Gard thank you madam
chair just a little bit confused on page
that two I guess but
line 22 it starts Roman numeral 7
there's no exhaustive definition of
anti-semitism as it can take many forms
then it goes on with the quote
anti-Semitism a certain perception of
Jews which maybe expresses hatred toward
Jews and it goes on my question is is
this to say that boycotting Israel is
anti-Semitic because it doesn't
specifically state that but it's just
kind of in
there as I think is intended in this
purpose
statement
um there as it says there's no
exhaustive definition of
anti-Semitism but um as you see further
down um on line 26 it's a certain
perception of Jewish people which may be
expressed as hatred um so rhetorical and
physical manifestations which a boycott
would be I think are covered by that
thank
you representative
schm thank you madam chair so I want to
pick up on what representative Gard was
starting into and that is that there is
a number of references uh or a number of
references with regard to
anti-jewish or anti-israel or
anti-Semitism and you referen in your
opening remarks uh that the October
7th
attack that um we're all very familiar
with uh are there there are no other
reasons for the for
possible
um anti- Israeli government uh action
with regard to the current situation
which is seeing as you know thousands of
gin in in Jeopardy uh on a whole series
of
bases not enough food not enough clean
water uh not enough medical supplies not
enough fuel not enough electricity if
any and so forth so um I'm I'm troubled
by the idea that that they this seems to
be focused on the idea of
anti-Semitism so the point I was trying
to make is that the governor's executive
order um came out before October 7th and
that in light of October 7th I thought
it was important to ctif it in a bill
given what happened on October 7th and
that's why the
bill okay thank
you other questions rep
in I would I could have missed it but
when you mentioned $100 million in
exports new Hamp from New Hampshire
exports this is a total number or is
this exports I'm just trying to
understand the qualifications of that
$100
million so that's my understanding and
the research that we did with
um the Bureau of economic Affairs that
there's over aund million of exports in
2021 from New Hampshire to
Israel
other I have a question um isn't you've
cited several cases
where discrimination against Israel or
whatever is
illegal and do you think it's necessary
for us to pass a law to say that we
won't do business with with companies
that commit criminal
acts that's why I'm here so yes okay
thank you I glad to have that out in the
open representative Brown uh thank you
madam chair uh thank you Senator did in
in your research or other testimony was
there
any um information about the impact that
this would have on any companies that
that do employ boycotts against
Israel no okay and followup followup
and I I'll guess that there was no
information on New Hampshire companies
that might be in that position none that
I'm aware
of again as I said before it
um the governor already I issued an
executive order this just codifies it
than Senator do you have the fiscal
note um this version doesn't have
anything mentioned it says we don't have
it yet and I have the uh fiscal note of
the introduced bill and I don't believe
there was an
amendment no there wasn't that we know
of uh what is the fiscal note
uh
well no change to
revenue
um an indeterminable increase of
expenditures and no
Appropriations so the fiscal note should
be attached to the bill um but that's
what it says I think we got the original
version the in the original version
that's correct okay thank
you
other
questions being none thank you Senator
great thank you very much representative
Shapiro thank you madam chair and
committee members I think um for the
record um I representative Joe Shapiro
from Keen representing keen and nine
small surrounding communities also for
the record I am Jewish with my mother's
parents arriving from Romania and my
father's from Lithuania in the early
20th century while they escaped European
the European Holocaust not all of their
extended families were able to come to
America and undoubtedly many of them
perished at the hands of the
Nazis so why would I come here today to
speak in opposition to SB
429 which would prevent the state of New
Hampshire from doing business with
companies who have been involved in
boycotting the state of
Israel let me be clear it is not because
I'm against Israel I have traveled to
Israel it is an amazing place with
amazing people who have made
extraordinary accomplishments in the
face of hostility and threats of
annihilation here are my reasons for
opposing this
bill first I believe this bill restricts
constitutionally protected free speech
in fact while the results have been
mixed in federal courts a number of
States including Kansas Arizona Texas
and Arkansas have had similar laws
blocked by federal
courts second this bill dishonors a
proud and historically important
tradition of nonviolent political
boycotts to bring social
change please consider the Montgomery
bus bus boycott started when Rosa Parks
refused to move to the back of the
bus in December of 1955 and ended with
desegregation of public transportation
in the South a year later also consider
the
movement in the US and worldwide in the
1980s to devest in the government of
South Africa which led to the end of a
partide and the election of Nelson
Mandela a few years later in
1964 1994 excuse me third if you believe
as I do that the attack on October 7th
was a Savage genocidal terrorist attack
against innocent Israeli civilians and
that it was not an isolated incident
during the second inapa in Israel
between 2000 and 2005 Israel's Israelis
were routinely routinely blown up on
buses merely for the fact of traveling
to work or going to
school if you believe that violence
against Israeli civilians has been a
frequently used tactic then why would
you choose to prohibit a protest tactic
that is nonviolent in J in nature
doesn't this incentivize
violence last reason representatives in
the New Hampshire house should know more
than anyone that one can disagree with
current laws be critical of certain
policies and make every effort to change
the direction of a government all while
remaining patriotic and fiercely loyal
to our state the same is true of Israel
laws that prohibit disagreement over
policy and ban nonviolent actions such
as boycotts to change such policies even
if you think some of the people doing so
are wrongheaded are just a step too far
I am not a member of the BDS movement
nor do I necessarily support the
specific goals of the BDS leadership but
I do not think that the state of New
Hampshire should participate in Banning
political speech and I hope you will
agree with me thank you are there any
questions representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so I'd
like to pursue the line of questioning
that I started with uh Senator
Bradley uh there are repeated references
to
anti-Semitism
uh and
I and I asked him whether it was not
possible to be uh against some of the
things that were happening um in Israel
without having anything to do with
anti-Semitism can you speak to that
particular
aspect um the answer is yes I think that
one can um be a supporter of Israel
believe in Israel's right to exist
believe in Israel's right to exist as a
religious um country um and disagree
with some of the policies of the Israeli
government um just like we do all the
time here um and unfortunately I think
the terminology of
anti-Semitism anti-Semitism is real I
mean I mean I don't want to pull out my
emails and show you some of the vile
anti-semitic emails that I've gotten
serving in the legislature it is a real
thing but I think it is a real problem
when when CR criticisms of certain
policies whether they been be in Israel
or any place else um is um is suppressed
by calling those people anti-semitic and
that sometimes
happens
thank you you've made my point other
questions thank you for your testimony
and I appreciate your uh keeping keeping
your remarks to the intent of the Bill
thank
you speaking of that we have a whole lot
of people who are opposed to the bill I
will will give you all a chance to speak
but I would like to say firstly that we
ought to concentrate on the bill I will
not
tolerate
saying trash talking Israel
essentially or blame or
um or and I would hope that you would
not be
repetitive we will listen to all of you
but uh believe me the the fifth time
something is said is way less effective
than the first Mr kti AJ
kti I hope you will try that's why
you're
first question yes please turn your
microphone on and introduce yourself my
name is AJ klei I'm 18 I've lived in New
Hampshire my whole
life um gez yeah I don't really know
where to start I guess I'll start here
where it says um on line 11 that these
boy cots you know often amount to ethnic
religious racial or nationality
discrimination um and I think that's
what representative Schmidt was just
talking about how and and the other
person who was just up here
equating being against a violent thing
that's going on to being against an
entire group of religious people or any
sort of group of people like you can
that's apples and oranges you can be
against the death and destruction and
famine and exploitation of millions of
people while also not hating Jewish
people I think that is very very obvious
and um yeah it's literally just the
freedom of political speech we I've
grown up hearing Live Free or Die I dude
like I'm so sick of the whole shtick of
freedom and this and that oh just just
get good grades just go to school and
you'll go to college and you'll be able
to get a house just like us and start a
family that's we're all figuring out
that that's total crap and and we're not
just going to sit by and and let it
happen I mean I'm
glad that I knew that this was going on
there's a whole lot of people in my age
that feel the same way as as me and as
these other people but don't even know
that things like this are happening um
so the last thing that we need is the
suppression of nonviolent boycotts like
in front of City Hall again nonviolent
have signs chanting like can you get
any what would be the alternative it's
exactly like that the last person was
saying it's almost like you're
incentivizing of of violent protest
because if you're left with no other
choice people are still angry people are
not going to change their minds just
because money isn't flowing to them not
everyone makes up their mind based on
how much cash is in their pockets and
I'm really sick of realizing growing up
and realizing that that's literally what
drives every single force in this
country I mean all the anti-boycott laws
that are around the country right now
which I was reading I think 220 million
Americans which is about 78% of americ
am an live in places where there are
already anti-b boycotting laws that's
literally insane to me that's insane I
don't understand how you can hear that
and not think that's insane when we are
the land of the free and Home of the
Brave
um yeah um I don't know I'm going to I
guess read something really quick that I
I said to the Manchester Board of Mayor
and Alderman and it was about a
ceasefire resolution then it's not this
paragraph doesn't really touch upon that
citizens around the world have been
conditioned to turn a blind eye to
catastrophe and our ancient values of
connectedness to our communities and to
the Earth have been replaced by self-
entitlement in the endless compulsion to
consume we are moths drawn to the flame
of industrialization and it's burning us
all up the majority of us mostly the
older Generations have slipped into a
sense of false Comfort inside a system
that exploits the working class for
everything we have but leaves us with
scraps because it's all we've ever known
someone please explain to me how natural
complex systems have sustained on Earth
for Millennia yet the modern Homo Sapien
is convinced he knows better based on
these past 200 years of
industrialization and the glorification
of rugged individualism if you ask me
the ongoing promotion of rugged
individualism within a hierarchial
society in which very few possess more
money and power than millions of us
combined it's simply or it's simply
something to keep taxpayers on their
hamster wheels I'm I'm sick of this crap
a lot of people are sick of this crap
the state divesting what does that have
to do with this
bill what does it not have to do with
this bill this bill prohibits a
discriminatory boycotts of Israel but
then it also says no that's
anti-Semitism but then it's also
anti-israeli government like can we
actually separate these things
anti-Semitism is being anti-jewish
people being anti-israeli government in
anti-israeli government policies is a
completely different thing so
different thank you that's all you got
to say to me real sweet thank you for
your testimony that's all I need to say
are there
questions representative Brown has a
question if you talk it up with me I'd
love to answer
questions what's up uh thank you madam
chair
um would you equate not buying Nike
sneakers from that company because of a
policy they have to a boycott of Israel
is that is that a similar in your mind
is that a
similar um free
speech uh expression of free speech I
mean yeah I mean it's not really like
Speech cuz you might not talk about it
but like I've decided to stop buying
McDonald's stop buying staru not that I
was ever have Celiac I don't really buy
that crap anyways but like you can make
decisions and have them be off of your
morality and then not shove it down
other people's throat and or you know
make it illegal to do the opposite like
I don't know yeah it's I I could choose
not to buy Nikes because um first of all
I'm broke I'll go to Savers and get some
like I'll get ones for five bucks at
Savers I mean it's more sustainable I
stopped buying fast fashion in general
it all ends up in a landfill I don't
know like yeah may may I follow
up once as a comment
yes aren't we all Lucky that you're able
to sit here and express this in our live
for your dice day because there's still
places in the world where you couldn't
do this
totally thank you thank and thank you
for coming up I didn't mean that in a
bad way no totally I take it as a
compliment thank you
okay other question representative
schmith has a question thank you madam
chair so you were here I believe uh when
Senator Bradley referenced that this
bill is about codifying the governor's
executive order
from half a year ago yeah has anything
changed uh with regard to the state of
is Israel since then that might change
the idea behind the governor's executive
order uh yeah I think definitely things
have changed yeah like October 7th
happened and then in
response we know what's going on I'm I'm
not going to sit here and tell you all
what's going on I hope to God that
you're all educating yourselves on
what's going on in the world since it's
like your job but anyway yeah I mean but
I also have to say like it's not just
like an entire shift in perspective
because of this one Massacre that's now
been going on for five six months 7
months like there's over 30,000 people
dead like yeah that's a very very big
thing to worry about but also there's
been massacres before this against the
Palestinian people um I mean I'm not
going to I'm not going to yeah I'm not
going to sit here and be like you know I
know every single one but I can tell you
for a fact it it didn't start with
October 7th and I
honestly I don't think it should matter
when where who started it there's
innocent people dying I think it's like
totally justified to be freaked out
about it if we weren't also exposed to
like violence and media like we would
all be we would see the footage of
what's going on over there we'd either
be lighting buildings on fire or like
curled up in a ball crying like that
that I should not have to open Instagram
and see dead children and I'm not like
I'll delete Instagram I know I have the
freedom to do that I'm just saying like
that's messed up I
I if if this is all I can do about the
dead children I see on my social media
Pages then I'm going to do it and if if
boycotting
non-violently uh a state and that is
using its policies and its power to
carry out a genocide and ethnic
cleansing um yeah I think that's I think
that makes a lot of sense to be angry
about that or at least you know
concerned yeah
seems like you've been doing a lot of
thinking uh the last couple years
so keep at it seems like it's a little
dictator ship keep at it there may be a
place for you at uh on this side of the
table at some point thank you that's
sweet I used to want to like work in
government yeah and then I realized um
the government sucks so not going to do
that okay anyone else I can be done no
thank you I'm so thank you for your test
I'm sure you enjoyed it pink pink shirt
person Katie
[Music]
carbonara hello okay um my name is Katie
carbonara um and I am from Keen so it
has been 2 and 1/2 months since we were
last here testifying against this bill
and in those 2 and a half months the
level of violence cruelty destruction
and
inity could you please concentrate on
the
bill AJ AJ AJ it's my turn to speak
thank
you this is concentrating on the bill
because this bill is dealing with the
state of Israel and it is concentrating
on the bill to make sure that we are all
aware of what the state of Israel is
currently doing in Gaza right now so I
would like to continue if that's okay
I we
have please continue but I think that we
need to concentrate on the actions of
our state government because that's what
we're here for so and I plan to speak to
that as well thank
you and in those two and a half months
the level of violence cruelty
destruction and inhumanity that we are
witnessing Gaza has only increased
exponentially as starvation is used as a
weapon as desperate people are massacred
over bags of flour as the targeted
murder of Aid workers and First
Responders only increases as we see
evidence of the horrific atrocities at
alifa hospital it is hard to believe
that this bill is still being considered
by this body we are now 6 months into a
genocide that has been live streamed for
the entire world to see that is being
funded by our tax dollars and it is an
evil thing that the only response of the
government of this state to this moment
is an attempt to crack down on the
boycott of Israel a legitimate form of
protest and free expression for any
person or business of conscience who
stands against the horrors we are
currently witnessing in Gaza and the
entirety of over 75 years of occupation
that the Palestinian people have
I urge this committee to understand the
role that you play at this pivotal time
in history the chance that you have
right now to stand for something beyond
the mundane politicking that seems to be
the majority of what goes on in these
Chambers to do what you can to throw
sand into the Machinery of genocide even
in the smallest way and to vote no on
this Bill thank you thank
you Maria
Kennedy I have a question
you you seem to be reading from a
prepared statement could you send it to
us so that we have it if you haven't
done so already Yes would can I email it
to you is that it's on my phone will be
fine thank okay I will fig thank
you um good afternoon my name is Maria
so Kennedy um I'm from
Lebanon uh New Hampshire I'm a law
student and I'm graduating next month um
I took time away from my coursework and
I drove over an hour today to ask you to
oppose SB
439 this is a ridiculous and
unconstitutional waste of this body's
time and of taxpayer money if the state
passes SB 439 and codifies the
governor's order they might as well cut
an enormous check to a civil liberties
organization
legal organization like care or the ACLU
that is because anti-boycott bills like
this represent a blatant violation of
our first amendment rights in fact I
used to work with First Amendment
lawyers and they referred to anti-bds
bills as donation or fundraising bills
because this type of legislation is so
frequently introduced and is also so
frequently judicially
defeated I have to ask when there are so
many issues New Hampshire residents face
homelessness Rising costs in health
healthare and education the opioid
epidemic why the state would gamble with
taxpayer money this way instead of
investing in our communities this bill
seeks to ensure that the state of Israel
which is the largest recipient of US
foreign aid receives even more of our
financial support and this comes at the
expense of local services and at a great
cost to overburden State officials who
will now have to screen and verify BDS
activity by companies while overseeing
State Investments and contracts
finally I am shocked that New Hampshire
is debating whether to sacrifice its
residents Free Speech rights in order to
privilege a foreign state currently
committing genocide Israel has killed
over 40,000 Palestinians in Gaza the us
and our federal Representatives like
Senators Hassen and Shaheen have
supported and facilitated this mass
murder if anything the state legislature
should be doing everything it can to
pressure our federal delegation to bring
on an end to the ongoing Slaughter thank
you very much and if you have have
questions I'm I'm also happy to email my
testimony thank you we would appreciate
receiving
it
questions Evelyn
Campbell hello my name is Evelyn kle I'm
from Lebanon and I'm here to oppose sen
a bill 4 39 as it was defeated last year
like this bill is an unacceptable attack
on New Hampshire people and businesses
ability to oppose genocide in Palestine
it infringes on our expressive conduct
and silences the explanatory speech this
is an attack on both our first amendment
rights to free speech and our 14th
Amendment rights for free associ free
association with BDF which is a
non-national but globally supported
movement to support Palestine and oppose
a partide In The Same Spirit as the
anti- partide boycotts that ended in
South
Africa these bills are been repeatedly
declared unconstitutional and in attacks
by in Texas Georgia Kansas and
Arizona and they will be declared
unconstitutional here as well we there's
no reason to overthrow our long-
stated support for companies to choose
which brands they want they want to sell
to us or to and to deny benefits to
people purely for their conduct and
speech solely to support the state of
Israel's
genocide thank you are there any
question thank you for your testimony
could you just say your name could you
just say your name more clearly I didn't
understand it at all Evelyn kampbell
thank you
representative laus thank you uh you
mentioned a number of uh court cases I
don't know if there were state or US
Supreme Court I was wondering if you
could email the committee citations for
at least some of them uh or if someone
here could I can by the end of previous
speaker all right thank
you okay thank you very much for your
testimony Al
Abad
hello um thank you for giving me the
time to speak uh I'm dram Abu I'm a
Palestinian American constituent of the
State of New Hampshire I'm here today on
which is one of the two major holidays
in My Religion a holiday that is a
somber reminder of loss and grief to
everyone in GDA right now I'm testifying
an opposition of New Hampshire State
Bill 439 because I am deeply concerned
about my family who are just trying to S
survive the horror that is taking place
right now in Reza and the West
Bank the grounds for this legislation is
to prevent discrimination and
anti-Semitism however as many of us have
seen anti-Semitism has become weaponized
by Israel as a means to allow them to do
whatever they so choose to Palestinians
and pro Palestinians around the world
definitions are important so please
allow me to clarify that anti-Semitism
means anyone who is against people that
speak semetic languages which includes
Arabic therefore this language is
anti-Semitic as it is supporting an
illegal apartheid state that murders and
ethnically cleanses indigenous
Arabs we should be able to criticize any
government without conflation of disc
discrimination of its
people the boycott divestments and
sanctions or BDS movement is the most
powerful form of protest and removing
this fundamental right is an attack on
Free Speech as well as
democracy in removing our ability to
utilize BDS this legislation is
extremely harmful towards individuals
who are experiencing persecution
oppression and genocide the US has not
done this for a single other country
including
itself if we are so worried about discri
ation why haven't we instituted
legislation to prevent islamophobia or
hatred against any other religious
groups experiencing discrimination we
ethnically cleansed the Native Americans
dropped atomic bombs on Japan and fought
pointless Wars in Vietnam Iraq and
Afghanistan when will we learn war is
not the answer 2023 was the deadliest
year for Palestinians since
1948 let that sink in we are on the
wrong side of History once again now
legislators are targeting our First
Amendment right to free speech I would
like to remind you that while we waste
our time arguing over anti-bds
legislation a genocide is taking place
several cities within New Hampshire have
passed ceasefire resolutions and yet
here we are trying to protect the
illegal Israeli apartheid regime through
illegal
means these Bill sponsors do not
represent us their constituents as they
are supporting and genocide we have been
fighting to put a stop to the Senators
completely ignored the majority of us
that testified in person and voted
against this bill at the last
hearing will you ignore us as
well we cannot turn a blind eye to the
most well documented genocide in human
history Israel's human rights violations
are well documented many Israel please
excuse me would you I I agree that you
do not approve the government of Israel
nor its recent actions could you please
talk about the bill this is relevant to
the bill because of the context and I'm
almost
done okay thank you many Israelis and
videos and on social media have even
confessed to or boasted of committing
atrocities but have not once been held
accountable I have brought some Visual
Evidence I would like to submit to you
these are photos of some of the human
rights violations and war crimes Israel
has committed against Palestinians
before you take your vote I would like
you to look at these photos and be held
accountable to them supporting this bill
despite the atrocities taking place
sends a clear message Israel is above
the law and Palestinian human rights do
not
matter free Palestine thank you for your
time may I pass the photos
forward yes we'll than take the
information Salam OD
day point of order Mr Madam chair
um
uh I know there's a lot of emotion here
but I'm I am in agreement with you I'm
failing to see where some of the
comments I am willing to accept that
they are opposed to Israel and they wish
to impose a boy boycott fort in order to
express that displeasure and I'm trying
to keep them focusing on what the how
that relates to the bill and I hope you
will uh you will do so appreciate that
thank
you good afternoon my name is Salam ODI
I was born and raised as a Palestinian
refugee in Jordan I have been a citizen
of Manchester New Hampshire since I was
16 years
old I am a former State commissioner on
the sadest of women
however of course I'm here to oppose the
bill boycott have been an effective
effectively used in the United States by
advocates for equal rights since Boston
Tea Party for crying out
loud these include boycotts led by civil
rights activists during the 1950s and
60s in order to advocate for racial
equality such as Montgomery Bus Boycott
and promote workers rights such as the
unit the United Farm Workers LED boycott
of table
grapes there are countless historical
moments when Americans are participated
in boycott to push human rights in other
countries the boycotting of Imperial
Japan during the late 1930 the
boycotting of Nazi Germany from 1933 to
1941 the boycotting of 1980 Summer
Olympics in me in Moscow and the
boycotting of South Africa
aparti Conger con Congress State and
civil rights leaders from all
communities should endu to preserve the
freedom of advocacy for
all um opposition anti-boycott
resolution and and leg
legislation thank you
so let me say
that for the past 30 years I only do my
grocery shopping I go to
Farms I have been
boycotting anything that's not made in
the
USA I have the right to choose who to
shop where sh based on what facts I
have I am a result of the Israeli
occupation there is over 10 million
refugees living in over 64 refugee camps
there is nothing pretty about Israel as
a matter of fact all my all my children
were born and raised in the state of in
Hampshire one of them he's a Navy SEAL I
taught my children to never recognize
such a thing as a state of Israel and I
will never recognize such a thing as a
state of Israel they are thieves
somebody who's a thief and they they
steal the land they make goods from our
our land and our trees and they sell it
here in the state of New Hampshire I
have the right to boycott it companies
have the right to boycott it you have no
right you have no right to tell the
people of New Hampshire they cannot
boycott and based on what what is your
reason beside let me say I am a citic
indigenous Palestinian woman so is my
children European Jews are not citic
people and they're absolutely not
indigenous or citic they don't belong in
Palestine so yes you're you're opposed
it to the Israeli government thank
you
BL Me Your Light
foot give it to uh representative man
py
if if uh is benan lightfood your husband
could you speak together sorry would you
like to speak together uh no do we need
thank you okay um is is this doing what
it's supposed to do yes it is we can
hear you thank you um my name is schom
Lightfoot I live in new EP switch and
I'm a member of New Hampshire's Jewish
Community I'm a United States citizen
and I'm also a citizen of the state of
Israel and I'm here to ask you to oppose
SB
439 um you ask to stay on topic yes
please um and we've mentioned the
questions about anti-Semitism a few
times so I want to at least touch on
that um standing up against the state of
Israel is not
anti-semitic um standing up for human
rights for international law for free
speech and for basic decency is not
anti-semitic the Zionist political
movement has taken over my religion and
taken out God law ethics and culture and
replace them with nationalism and
allegiance to a particular
country then it tries to legitimize
Israel's atrocious Behavior by claiming
that this represents Jewish interests
and it keeps people afraid of speaking
out lest they be called
anti-semitic New Hampshire does not need
to accept
this um I'm very unhappy with some of
the logic that this bill is using um to
try to protect Israel from boycott at
the cost of our Free
Speech boycotting Israel is not
discrimination against anyone it would
be silly to argue that someone choosing
to boycott country that was Christian or
that was Muslim because of Human Rights
abuses is discriminating against
Christian or Muslim people or that
boycotting Russian or Chinese goods for
human rights reasons is discriminating
against Russian or Chinese people and
it's similarly silly to claim that a
boycott against Israel constitutes
discrimination against Jews or any group
of people in New
Hampshire at the senate committee
hearing on this bill a senator asked a
testifier whether she believes Israel
has the right to
exist criticism of Israel's human rights
abuses is often put down by saying well
Israel has a right to
exist as if violating human rights and
international law please con please
concentrate on on the bill we we don't
need to know what convinced the Senate
to to go forward with it okay thank you
for calling me on that
um give me a moment
sorry every
measure against boycotting Israel as
this bill is holds us farther from
realizing a just
peace and leads us to more loss and
sorrow all
around please don't vote to further a
continuation of these problems and
please protect our right to freedom of
speech and expression by standing
against
s439 thank you very much thank you for
your
testimony Abdul let
I can't I can't quite read the
handwriting I'm somebody in Lebanon y
That's
me hello honored members of the House
committee my name is abdulatif I am a
resident of Lebanon New Hampshire W
2 today is April 10th today is the
Muslim holiday
Eid a year ago children in Gaza were
buying new clothes to wear for the
holiday please let me finish there's a
major point over here a year ago
children were buying new clothes for the
holiday this year children are in burial
shrouds on this holiday I say this to
say that this bill is being heard on Eid
the Muslim holiday a day when many
people who are Muslim in the state who
are directly affected by this bill again
a bill that says that businesses that
support Palestinian protest that are you
know BDS against Israel again many
Muslims in this state have a say in this
have a stake in this debate this hearing
is on the Muslim holiday it's the same
as if you this bill was being heard on
Christmas right how many people could
make it in that circumstance so I really
want this to be something if you can
flag this for the Dei committee for the
future uh just I'm sure it was an
accident I'm sure like you know it
happens there's so many dates but if you
be flagged for the Dei committee because
again it affects Muslim residents of the
State directly quite often I would
really really greatly appreciate that
now to to add to that okay I am a
ethnically Jewish Muslim American I work
with Palestinian students I work with
many students who want to start
businesses in the state who want to do
work in the state and their work they
Envision they they want to be involved
in boycott they want to be able to
express their economic free speech and
for this state house to not give them
that ability to to say that we're not
going to work with you if you do this in
the future it economically damages our
state frankly it is a blatant violation
of free speech and I really really hope
and I know last year when it came to
this committee uh you know it didn't
move past the committee I really hope
it's the case again this year uh because
it's strange to be here again A year
later after so much more has happened
and to and to see how in nearby States
we've seen Palestinian protesters in
Burlington be physically harmed and now
to say that economically there's
restrictions on what they're able to do
I really really hope that it does not
move past this committee and I thank you
for your time and I'm sorry to have
stopped you from saying that over there
against the holiday you know it's an
emotional day I appreciate it thank you
yes if you would have your group send
the the list of holidays to the I will
happily do so to the state house we can
avoid this sort of thing absolutely I
wasn't aware of it when I scheduled the
hearing no no worries and Eid Mubarak by
the way because is the holiday thank
you Joshua May
prouts
it could
be the uh handwriting leaves a little
Vis little options for uh guessing
there good afternoon committee members
thank you very much for welcoming uh
comments uh my name is Joshua myrowitz
I'm a professor Meritus of communication
and media studies at the University of
New Hampshire I sent you a long detail
probably more footnotes than you used to
get statements so I don't want to repeat
that but I wanted to add a little
context uh and also to say that I
understand the impetus for this bill and
a way to protect me a and mine um and uh
I haven't really slept well since
October 7th um uh but I speak in strong
opposition to this bill I was born and
grew up in New York City not that long
after the Holocaust wiped out most of my
uh family my parents sent me and my
older sister to an Orthodox Jewish Day
school and I had to take public
transportation back and forth and I
still remember the scowl on the face of
the public uh
Q7 bus driver uh where he would open the
door shout out and just drive by
without stopping the bus I was it was
not until I was 15 that I and my family
uh could go to so-called exclusive
Resorts such as Wentworth by the Sea
here in New Hampshire uh exclusive meant
that it excluded people like like me uh
so we've had a lot of progress but I
still experienced a lot of
anti-Semitic uh incidents and with that
discrimination uh background it felt
like a life-saving miracle that there
was this country formed the day year
before I was born uh with our ancient
Homeland like walking through the Bible
where Jews with a majority and where we
would be equal and where my Israeli
cousins miraculously were taller more
athletic more uh uh uh Stronger looking
than uh me and my uh e Exile cousins uh
Israel as your text your bill says as
many great wonders and ancient and Tech
Modern and technological high-tech um
and um but as I've reflected more on
this uh equality that I had I could
become an instant citizen of Israel uh
anyone with one Jewish grandparent can
become a citizen of Israel and by God I
had all
four and but that is but then what that
means is that this is discrimination in
my favor and it's uh discrimination
against people who living there and
those people support and about the bill
those many of those people support a
boycott because of Israel illegally
occupying uh West Bank and East
Jerusalem for 56 years and as uh Amnesty
International and Human Rights group and
the Israeli Human Rights group at selum
which means in the image in the image of
God and uh hundreds of uh whistleblower
soldiers IDF soldiers talk about massive
discri discrimination and uh you know it
took many many of us maybe longer than
it should have to realize this this uh
status and U you have in uh I mean the
what you're prohibiting is people in
this bill if it were to pass you would
prohibit people uh against checkpoints
travel bans Jews only roads nighttime
home invasions threats and verbal abuse
arbitrary arrest beatings EXT digal
killing this bill is about New Hampshire
I'm afraid we don't well you're limiting
people in New Hampshire
from from uh joining this B and I
personally at this moment have not
joined the boycot but I certainly
recognize the rights of people to do
that as a form of nonviolent protests
and also in terms of the protection of
me when you eliminate as other people
have said the opportunity for people to
protest non-violently as happened in
South Africa uh you make you put me in
mine at at at greater risk because then
we are more targeted for the only form
of protest that allows now and I
detailed some background of that also as
has been hinted out here um one of the
reasons there's a sharp rise in
so-called anti-semitic
incidents in in uh in the country and
the world is because groups like the
Anti-Defamation League Define anyone who
asks who supports the boycott or Pro who
asks for a ceased fire or uses from The
River To The Sea phrase as being
anti-semitic so I don't think those are
anti-semitic and I think this I I think
this bill is actually more anti-semitic
because it puts me and and other Jews
and also interestingly archaeological
digs show that Palestinians and Jews
have common DNA we are our we are
Semitic people and the Peace of Israelis
Israeli Jews and the Peace of
Palestinians are intertwined we cannot
really be safe alone without the other
being being safe and some of the
high-tech wonders as we've we learned in
recent days in Israel have been used to
use AI to identify targets and to kill
whole families and the neighbors so I I
strongly urge you uh not to uh support
this bill to let people have free
association and free views and to work
for a stronger more just world where we
are we are protected by protecting each
other thank you very much thank you and
I'm sure representative Schmidt would
like a copy of your your
test if representative Dolan and then
Brown thank you madam chair um and thank
you for taking a question as a
professor um I'm curious to know what
you are currently teaching your students
about things like this and do do you are
you discussing Hamas and how they
started this mess that we find ourselves
in representative billan could we please
keep try and focus on the bill
so should I respond to that question if
you can briefly I'm sure we're we're all
fascinated well since I'm uh retired I'm
my teaching at the moment is directed
more at
you and I you know I like to have not
just five minutes but at least 50
minutes prefer an hour and 20 or two
hours so but we can communicate that
later but uh what I try in in in my
teaching what I try to do is teach
Concepts that help people understand uh
the interaction one of them with
Israel uh and Hamas is actually to look
at it as a relationship where how they
each bring out in the other the very
thing they claim they do not want to
have and they give each other the
necessary uh provocation to keep
attacking each other so it's also it's
almost like applying a marital therapy
concept to uh where often the couple
agrees on the facts but not who starts
each inter action he drinks a lot he and
she nags him she says he drinks so I nag
him he says I nag him she he said she
nags me so I drink and they just keep
increasing that spiral and that's what
part of what uh can explain a lot of
things that happen with a MOS but Israel
Israel started Hamas as a way of
splitting the Palestinians and having a
poster child yes for why no peace was
possible and they wouldn't have to give
up the land so we look at conceptual
things in in that country and in other
countries around the world
and I'm accessible to provide a lot more
information if people want by phone or
by writing and I I I deeply footnoted
what I sent you with a rich set of stuff
to dig
into uh thank you madam chair certainly
if you think it's not if it's not
related let me
know going back to the question I asked
the first young man that came up here I
I really need clarified by you or
someone if I decide to boycott Nike
because I don't like their policy on
whatever is that the same as boycotting
let me let me back up a little bit
there's one piece can you tell me
boycotting of Israel is that just a
statement that I don't agree with them
or is that an effort to hurt the
country in some way or another those are
two different things to me right well I
think different PE I think
the motivations vary because this is an
opportunity but the the the use the part
of it that I think all of us who have
been spoken against the bill share is
that people who want to try to change
bad policies and move things toward a
more peaceful tomorrow uh want to use a
nonviolent means of protesting uh
rampant violations of international law
and take away the power of violent uh
violent protest in you know in 2018 2019
there was Hamas did a nonviolent protest
where they simply marched to the Border
uh of Gaza and Israeli snipers killed
over 200 of them and wounded many many
others so that taught them nonviolence
is not an option we need as many
nonviolent options as as we can and this
bill is working against that and it's
not uh it's not it's not the way to go
we want to leave people freedom of
Association freedom of as freedom of
action for multiple
motivations but Let Freedom Ring thank
you thank you representative
Schmidt thank you Madame chairman so I
believe you were here at the beginning
when Senator Bradley was introducing his
bill um and I reference the fact that
that the first page references
anti-Semitism
repeatedly um he said that this bill
is
to is to codify the
governor's executive order back
then um six months have happened in the
meantime so if if the
situation has
changed and if uh if there are other
ways of other reasons for opposing
Israeli
policy or the policy of the government
of
Israel uh would that in any way be
anti-semitic not at all and that's again
with this odd thing
that
an anti-Semitism has become broadly
expanded to include anyone who raises
any question about an Israeli
government's policies and Israel you
know we Israel is not the isra of yak
Rabin and uh uh and uh the peacemakers
and uh Shimon perz Israel now is led by
ministers who agree that yak Rabin was
appropriately assassinated because he
was going to give away land that God
gave to the Jews and uh thank you for
answering I'll just say you see I'll
just say one final horrifying thing many
of the in the government see October 7th
as the opportunity they've been waiting
for to De make Gaza uh uninhabitable and
to reestablish Jewish settlements and
land given to them by God this is not a
this is not a philosophy I think New
Hampshire wants to
support thank
you any other
questions thank you for your testimony
all right thank you very much and since
I'm retired I have plenty of time to
answer more time to answer questions by
email or well we're already uh 45
minutes over over what we expect no I
mean I mean after
today uh greetings M uh Madam chair and
the members of the committee my name is
Bam Lightfoot I live in new Switch New
Hampshire and as a religious Jew I ask
you to oppose Senate bail
439 there many things have been said
we've um I had the luxury of living uh
living and learning in the state of
Israel and there's a lot of things when
you actually have been there and you've
seen things understanding what's going
on makes a lot more sense the uh
Palestinian Christian Community have
reached out to the world and to to on to
for BDS which is this what this bill is
about this bill is discussing BDS and is
and saying we to to prevent any state
contracts the BDS movement was started
by the Palestinians and it's reaching
out and saying we need a we want peace
and to P they have put the Christian
Palestinian Community has put together
the BDS and to pull from their statement
that they made the Kiros doc which is
the word of Christian Palestinians to
the world about what's happening in the
state of state of Israel the Palestinian
Christians asks us to engage in boycots
device and sanctions against the Israeli
occupation they asked us to put pressure
on Israel to take uh measure legal
measures to obligate his government to
end its disregard and they seek to end
the existing e evil to liberate both
perator and victims of Injustice this
bill claims aims to prevent
anti-Semitism but it is actually the the
breeding ground of anti-Semitism this
you know you know the state of Israel
has a strong propaganda machine they
make outlandish claims of and their
crimes and as long as someone buys into
the claim even as until it's debunked it
allows them to Foster their crimes this
is the point of BDS is to actually call
this out and to St it in a peaceful
manner Senate Bill 439 claims that New
Hampshire is benefits from dealings with
the state of Israel but these benefits
are spying in surveillance they aid in
the suppression of protest distance and
healthy political discourse the things
that we're trying to just do here and
today these benefits are useful in
totalitarian regime and not in
democracy
the state of Israel does not represent
the Jewish people the Bale say talks
about uh preventing seism and this is a
political entity and I with many rabbis
and Jewish voice for peace and many
other organizations
asked to actually do the be to support
the BDS movement and this Veil is
explicitly trying to silence
us our Jewish brothers and Christians in
the Holy Land are asking us for this
request and it's our obligations as
fellow citizens of the world of a
community this will affect us here
affect our communities of the passage
and I ask you to answer the the call for
help and to oppose Senate Bill 439 thank
you thank
you Saia
Ahmed
good
afternoon my name is Saia Ahmed I'm a
resident of Lebanon New Hampshire and
I'm a Staff attorney at Palestine legal
I'm here today to voice my opposition to
Senate Bill 439 which threatens to keep
companies who boycott Israel from
receiving State funding and completely
mischaracterizes the boycott movement in
support of Palestine as a movement for
hate s SP 439 seeks to prohibit
businesses that choose to boycott Israel
from receiving State Investments and
contracts in a nutshell what this bill
is attempting to do is to silence speech
the first amendment protects Free Speech
the government cannot impose through
conditions what it cannot outright ban
government restrictions like this cannot
be based on the desire to punish or curb
First Amendment activities that seek to
promote social and political change as
the US Supreme Court has made clear in
NAACP versus Clayborn speech on public
issues isues has always rested on the
highest rung of the hierarchy of First
Amendment
values the court has also repeatedly
said that government officials
determinations about what constitutes an
acceptable view cannot infringe on one's
right to freely Express their political
views this is what SB 439 is attempting
to do it wants to quash speech that its
drafters disagree with by making sure
that anyone who disagrees with them
faces Financial
consequences boycotts based on issues of
ethical concern also Run Deep in our
history as a country boycotts to oppose
racial segregation or apartheid South
Africa for example why would boycotts
for Palestinian rights be treated any
differently what this legislation would
do is Chill speech in New Hampshire is
that what this body is trying to do it
would tell New Hampshire residents like
myself that if we speak out for human
rights we could be held accountable we
could face consequences
this bill is aimed at businesses and the
Free Speech rights of business owners
but its implications will not stop there
similar laws have been misrepresented
and abused in order to chill activism in
support of Palestine in general to
cancel cultural events to prevent public
talks at universities your actions in
supporting this one bill could have
devastating consequences beyond what
this bill is even aimed to
do lastly SP
439 also also wholly relies on
falsehoods Section 1 v15 describes the
movement for boycotting Israel as a
quote unquote dedicated hate movement s
SP 439 grossly uses this lie as a
premise to justify silencing speech in
support of Palestinian rights the
movement to boycott Israel let's be
clear is not a hate movement it is a
Grassroots movement for people to use
their individual financial decisions to
avoid complicity in the Israeli
government's actions and to use their
Collective economic pressure to
encourage Israel to end its dis
discriminatory
practices SB 439 then goes on to
reference the definition of
anti-semitism under the international
Holocaust remembrance act or otherwise
known as Ira which conflates
anti-zionism with
anti-Semitism this legislature needs to
be very clear it is a protected right to
be able to express anti-zionist
political views one's views against a
political entity like Israel SP 439
illegally attempts to infringe on that
right freedom of speech a core tenant of
our state and of our nation thank you
thank you for your
testimony Bob
Sanders okay thank
you okay I promise to tell you nothing
that you haven't heard now I'm trying to
tell you something that you haven't
heard before um so I this is the first
time I've testified I've been a reporter
for 30 years this the first time i' I've
covered so many of these meetings and
I've heard so many people repeat
themselves so I know what you're going
through um so I'm speaking here as a
former business reporter for New
Hampshire Business Review um the that
can now speak out on issues because I'm
no longer a reporter and um and also as
a Jew who organized an A A an open
letter uh against what Israel is doing
um that's
64 uh 67 Jews have signed on to in New
Hampshire um so and this was in one
week uh By Word of Mouth and by word of
email now not not social media not going
viral anything and this just was
released
today um and that was to the
Congressional Delegation but back to the
bill
um uh one thing I've learned as a
reporter is businesses don't like
government telling them what to
do and this is telling businesses what
to do it's not this that say don't do do
this because you might hurt the public
or don't do this because you might
pollute the you know the air or don't do
it's don't do this because we don't
agree with your opinion and we're going
to take your contracts away because we
don't like what you're saying or what
you're doing you said we we don't like
the fact that you're not doing business
with Israel so no contract we don't like
the and it could do this with any
country we don't like what you're you
know if if you're not doing business in
Canada for some reason you know we'll
pull your
contract I mean I think that's why you
rejected this last time and I expect
this why you're going to reject it again
um I just want to say in terms of the
anti-em this has been said many times by
other people but just 67 Jews in New
Hampshire and this just who found out
about it are saying that what Israel is
doing is wrong
they're saying they want to ceasefire
they want to cut off Aid um uh military
aid to Israel and they want humanitarian
Aid to get in there so there're are all
these Jews anti-semitic because they're
criticizing
Israel are they
self-hating I mean that's kind of what
the the bill implies in its opening
statement um that if you criticize
Israel You're anti-Semitic and I think
that's this is you know evidence that
that's not
true so that's all I have to say thank
you I appreciate if you want I a
different Viewpoint I want you can um
I'll give you the letter it's not
directly related to this but it shows
the number of Jews that have opposed in
with all their names thank
you I give it to somebody or give it to
someone at the end we'll we'll pass pass
it
along is there anyone else to testify on
Senate Bill
439 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing we do not have time to vote on
it so and I'm opening the hearing on
Senate Bill
yes right over
there
what I no it's Senator
pearls
318 if you'd like to introduce
it that will help Senator Pearl had to
leave half an hour
ago
sure
318 then you have to
take people almost convinced me to vote
for the
bill
just yeah exactly well good thing we're
going to S down for a day
yeah thank you I thank God I couldn't
hear her okay
thank you Madame chair um I'm here to
introduce did you start the public
hearing she went like
this just a second we'll let a few
people could you take your conversations
outside please we're moving on to a
totally different
topic thank
you okay please proceed thank you um
madam here I'm here to introduce Senate
Bill
318 which is relative to the adoption of
a social work ler
compact I believe that this is very
similar to the house bill that passed
the house um although it left the
committee without recommendation left
the committee without recommendation and
um I believe there are some people here
from oplc who might be able to answer
any questions but they may not be
necessary no the um I have no no
testimony on this and thank you you're
welcome and as representative groa
mentioned this bill is identical to
House Bill
1190 which has a passed the house and is
in the
Senate and therefore we don't need to do
anything with this and I'm going to T
the gab will over and
introduce the non- gerine
amendment
welcome Madam
chair thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Carol Maguire mayac
27 and Amendment
1429 which we have a good supply of
copies you may may not be at your desk
it's there's copies over there
gohe
this this amendment which completely
replaces the unnecessary content of
Senate Bill
is basically four sections from the
amendment to House Bill
1271 that the subcommittee works so hard
on it does not address the Guardians at
lium or the acupuncturists which were of
concern to various members of the
committee IT addresses the Manufacturing
Housing
installation board made
advisory IT addresses
the uh what's the next
part s the nursing home administrators
board made advisory which is also not a
problem and not strongly opposed by the
board it it combines the boards of
Massage Therapy
and
uh raiki and other Asian Bodywork
techniques at their request they're
already an Advisory Board this just
gives them a bit of a broader scope
reflexology of course and then it
deletes the registration of medical
technicians because the medical
technicians
didn't don't consider themselves
Professionals in that way they haven't
there's never been a board the board
they've never been able to do anything
and uh the subcommittee strongly felt
that we didn't want to give people the
illusion that we were regulating medical
technicians when we actually weren't so
this is as I said a small portion of
what was in that Amendment um
it should
be relatively non-controversial and I
hope you will support it thank you very
much are there any questions yes
representative leas yeah uh if I'm
remembering correctly ask I'm asking if
I'm remembering correctly that we
actually got rid of the registration
medical technicians and I think House
Bill 1410 if I remembering the number
right but since it was in this bill it
had to be removed well we that this bill
is in fact going to subcommittee because
just because it's you know it's a the
amendment we need to make sure that
there aren't any stupid mistakes in it
uh and that's one thing is we've already
repealed that board we don't need to do
it
twice okay thank you yeah I well sub
commmittee can deal with it but yeah the
intent is this is a small portion of
that Amendment carefully selected to be
um ready for final
review any other questions
seeing done thank you for your
testimony would anybody else like to
speak on Amendment 1429
H seeing none I'll close the hearing on
the
amendment pass the gavel back I believe
okay that's it for today yeah and we're
referring this to licensing committee
subcommittee congratulations
Tony
and we will adjourn for the day thank
you
everyone
e